PROHIBIT FOR TRAPPING FOR
COMMERCIAL OR RECREATIONAL
PURPOSES AND PROHIBIT THE SALE
OF RAW FOR IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
TRAPPING CALIFORNIA'S DONE AN
EXTREMELY SMALL SCALE TODAY IN
HIS BROUGHT IN VERY LITTLE
INCOME INTO THE STATE WHICH WAS
ONLY ABOUT FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS LAST YEAR.
HOWEVER CONTINUES BE INHERENTLY
CRUEL AND INHUMANE PRACTICE FOR
THE ANIMALS TRAPPED IN CAN HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES SUCH AS
KILLING PETS AND PROTECTED
WILDLIFE.
DESPITE REQUIREMENTS IN STATE
LAW FOR THE TRAPPING PROGRAM TO
COVERED SOME COST TRAPPING
LICENSE FEES NOT COVER THE
ACTUAL COST OF IMPLEMENTING
STATE -- TRAPPING PROGRAM.
AB TWO SEVENTY THREE WOULD END
THE USE OF TAXPAYER FUNDS TO
SUBSIDIZE FOR TRAPPING AND
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S NATIVE
WILDLIFE FROM CRUEL AN OUTDATED
PRACTICES.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT THIS
BILL WILL NOT AFFECT THE
TRAPPING FOR PEST CONTROL
DEPREDATION OR PROPERTY
PROTECTION IT WOULD MAINTAIN THE
ABILITY TO TRAP IN ORDER TO
MANAGE WILDLIFE.
WHICH MAY BE ENTERING CROPS OR
PROPERTY WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NINE ABOUT VERY GOOD
THANK YOU -- WE HAVE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT MORNING.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
NICHOLAS PSYCHIC DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR SOCIAL
COMPASSION LEGISLATION AND PROD
CO SPONSOR BABY.
TWO SEVEN THREE I'LL KEEP IT
SHORT.
NOT REITERATE SOME OF THE POINTS.
THAT THE AUTHOR MADE BUT I WILL
SAY THAT -- TRAPPING IS
HORRENDOUSLY CRUEL AS CONSUMERS
ARE LEARNING VIA SOCIAL MEDIA
AND OTHER OUTLETS.
SHOWING TERRIFIED ANIMALS
CROUCHING IN FEAR TRYING
DESPERATELY TO ESCAPE THE
IMMINENT THE NOT ONLY DO TARGET
MAMMALS FEEL THIS PAIN BUT SO DO
MANY OTHER NON TARGET ANIMALS.
TRAPS DO NOT DISCRIMINATE SO IS
NOT UNCOMMON FOR TRAPPERS TO
FIND HOUSEHOLD PETS BIRDS.
ENDANGERED IN RED LISTED SPECIES
ANOTHER ANIMALS DYING OR DEAD IN
THEIR TRAPS.
WITH THAT I'LL PASS THE MIKE TO
OUR OTHER WITNESS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MORNING MORNING I'M JENNY
KEATING WITH THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATION WITH
MORE THAN A HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
A FIVE YEARS AGO A SINGLE
TRAPPER OPERATING ALONG THE
BOUNDARY OF JOSHUA TREE NATIONAL
PARK KILLED ENOUGH BOBCATS IN
ONE SEASON TO SEVERELY DEPLETE
THE LOCAL POPULATION OF THE
SPECIES.
TURNING ANIMAL FREQUENTLY
OBSERVED IN APPRECIATED BY
TOURISTS AND LOCALS ALIKE INTO A
SPECIES NOW FIVE YEARS LATER
THAT IS STILL RARELY SEEN.
IN RESPONSE CALIFORNIA WISELY
BAND BOBCAT TRAPPING IN THE
STATE THE PROBLEM ISN'T LIMITED
BOBCATS AS APPROXIMATELY A DOZEN
NATIVE SPECIES ARE STILL
TARGETED FOR THEIR FOR LAST YEAR
A SINGLE TRAPPER OPERATING IN
AND AROUND THE RECENTLY
DESIGNATED SAN GABRIEL MOUNTAINS
NATIONAL MONUMENT COURT KILLED
MORE THAN A HUNDRED GRAY.
FOXES IT'S SAN GABRIEL MONUMENT
WAS DECLARED BY PRESIDENT OBAMA
IN SIGNIFICANT PART TO PROTECT
WILDLIFE FOR THE BENEFIT OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
CALIFORNIA LAW ALLOWS A SINGLE
FUR TRAPPER TO SYSTEMATICALLY
DEPLETE THE WILDLIFE IN THIS
AREA TO THE DEPTH DETRIMENT OF
NATURAL ECOSYSTEMS AND THE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO VISIT THE
MONUMENT ANNUALLY.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY'RE
MORE FOXES IN.
OTHER REGIONS OF CALIFORNIA AND
REGULATED TRAPPING THAT OCCURS
UNDER CURRENT LAW CAN HAVE REAL
IMPACTS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AFFECTING WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
EFFORTS AND THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE
IN RECREATION.
IN THE AREA.
BY PROHIBITING COMMERCIAL FOR
TRAPPING IN CALIFORNIA AB TWO
SEVENTY THREE WILL PROTECT NOT
JUST THE WILDLIFE AND ECOLOGY OF
THE STATE BUT ALSO THE TOURISM
DEPENDENT COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
TIED TO HEALTHY WILDLIFE
POPULATIONS.
OUTDOOR INDUSTRY FOUNDATION
ESTIMATES THAT MORE THAN FIVE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS ENGAGING
WILDLIFE VIEWING IN SOME MANNER
CONTRIBUTING OVER THREE AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS THE STATE'S
ECONOMY.
IN SOME WAY THE LOOK AT
ECOLOGICALLY ECONOMICALLY OR
ETHICALLY ENDING FOR TRAPPING IN
CALIFORNIA IS LONG OVERDUE I
RESPECTFULLY URGE A YES VOTE ON
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO HAVE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THIS
MORNING.
TIME THAT WELL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ABOUT ROBINSON ON BEHALF
OF THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE
UNITED STATES AND SUPPORT GOOD
THANKS SIR.
DOESN'T MATTER NOT LIKE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE FUND IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO CREDIT WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL HERE IN SUPPORT.
HOW MUCH OTHERS IN SUPPORT?
I O KO D. N. CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
OF WILDLIFE REHABILITATED IS IN
SUPPORT.
HOW MUCH MAN?
SACRAMENTO COUNTY GREEN PARTY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR I CAN BOOSTER
PROJECT KILEY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DOLLAR SO POLITE.
GOOD MORNING ERIN HOW THE
SACRAMENTO FROM PROJECT COYOTE
AND CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
I GENOMIC.
A CONNECTION EARTH IN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI AND THEN AT WHEELER AND I AM
THE PRESIDENT FOUNDER OF
CONNECTION EARTH AND WE WORK
GLOBALLY TO SAVE.
ENDANGERED WILDLIFE AND WE ARE
IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND
WE REPRESENT ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CONSTITUENTS.
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES.
THANK YOU.
I THEIR HARRISON ROBERT OF FROM --
OAKLAND AND I SUPPORT -- THERE
BEAR DELAWARE FROM NEWPORT BEACH
NAY SUPPORT.
DICK WOULD SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
YOU.
HELEN DILLINGER HUMANITARIAN IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
BUT ORGANIZATION.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IN NINETEEN DO YOU HAVE ANY IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
MORNING.
MY MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS NOEL
CREAMERS.
FROM YOUR FEDERATION WELL A PRE
SHEET THAT THE BILL CONTINUES TO
ALLOW FOR TRAPPING TO TO PROTECT
LIVESTOCK AND DEAL WITH PROPERTY
DAMAGE AND LOSS.
WE DO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE BAN.
ON RECREATIONAL TRAPPING.
AND HERE'S WHY.
OUR MEMBERS DO ALLOW TRAPPERS
ACCESS TO THEIR LANDS. TWO
RECREATIONALLY TRAP THE REASON
HEY DO THIS IS BECAUSE THAT
THEN REDUCES THE POTENTIAL
IMPACT AND LOSS IN THE FUTURE SO
THAT THEY DON'T NEED.
TO CAN USE TRAPPERS HOPEFULLY OR
THEY REDUCE THE NEED TO HAVE
THOSE TRAPPERS AFTER A LOSS
OCCURS SO THEY CAN GET THAT CAN
ALLOW TRAPPERS TO COME OUT AND
PREVENTATIVE WE WORK.
SO THEY DON'T NEED IT LATER.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT.
THERE'S A BIT OF A DISAGREEMENT
ABOUT THE POTENTIAL COSTS THAT
THIS BILL.
THAT THE TRAPPING PROGRAM
CREATES FOR THE STATE TO THERE
WAS AN ANALYSIS A COUPLE YEARS
AGO BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE.
THAT ESTIMATES THAT THE TOTAL
COST OF OPERATING THE TRAPPING
PROGRAM IS A LITTLE OVER SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WHICH MEANS TO COVER THAT COST.
WITH THE LOW LEVEL OF TRAPPING
THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA.
LICENSE COSTS NEED TO BE A
HUNDRED AND SEVEN DOLLARS.
CURRENTLY THERE A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR DOLLARS SO THE FEES
ARE COVERING THE COST OF
OPERATING THAT PROGRAM.
I THINK WHERE THE DISAGREEMENT
OCCURS IS THE PROPONENTS OF THE
BILL BELIEVE THAT.
THOSE COSTS SHOULD ALSO COVER
THE COST OF ENFORCEMENT.
HOWEVER.
IF TRAPPING IS BEYOND.
THAT DOES NOT ELIMINATE THE NEED
TO HAVE WARDENS OUT. TO ENFORCE
AND MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE AREN'T
TRAPPING.
SO THAT ENFORCEMENT COST REMAINS
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT WE
HAVE A TRAPPING PROGRAM.
I'VE HEARD WARDEN SAY HAVING
LICENSE TRAPPERS OUT THERE IS
HELPFUL.
BECAUSE IT CAN BE EYES AND EARS
TO THE WARDENS. TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE AREN'T ACTING
ILLEGALLY THEY CAN I'M PROVIDE
TIPS TO THE WARDEN'S SO YOU
ACTUALLY LOSE THAT WHEN YOU
BANNED TRAPPING.
THE MINUTES FOR THOSE REASONS
THAT WE OPPOSE THE BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
I MISTER CHAIRMAN RESERVE THE
COMMITTEE MARKEDLY WITH
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION.
ARE -- MEMBERS AND OUR
ORGANIZATION MANAGE LANDS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE WETLAND
PROPERTIES.
AND WE CURRENTLY RECEIVE
TRAPPING SERVICES FOR FOR FOR
FREE FROM RECREATIONAL TRAPPERS --
TO CONTROL THINGS LIKE SKUNKS
RACCOONS POSSUMS WHICH PREY ON
WATER FOUND S. -- THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE WATER FELL MANAGERS TO
NOW BASICALLY PAY FOR THOSE
SERVICES.
AND USE PASS CONTROL OPERATORS
WHO AREN'T NECESSARILY FAMILIAR
WITH THE PROPERTIES AND YOU KNOW
THE CHALLENGES THAT THEY FACE
OUT THERE.
WELL WHEN BUDGETS AS YOU ALL
KNOW ARE VERY LIMITED -- AND
ADDING THESE COSTS ON THERE IS
DEFINITELY GONNA FACT OTHER
WETLAND MAINTENANCE AND OTHER
ACTIVITIES CONSERVATION
ACTIVITIES SO.
CAN BE LESS MONEY AND AND
RESOURCES FOR THOSE SERVICES.
ONE THING THAT REALLY IS --
TROUBLING FOR US IS IS THE
PRESIDENT ALSO THAT THIS BILL
SETS I'M YOU'RE BASICALLY
BANNING A METHOD OF TAKE FOR
RECREATIONAL PURPOSES.
AND I'D REMIND THE COMMITTEE
THAT HUNTING AND FISHING TO ARE
DOWN AT TIMES FOR RECREATIONAL
PURPOSES SO WE MAY HAVE PEOPLE
COME BACK AND ASK.
WHY AREN'T THOSE -- ACTIVITIES
AFFECTED AS WELL.
IS YOU KNOW TO TRAPPING IS
ALREADY HIGHLY REGULATED BY THE
CALIFORNIAFISH AND GAME
COMMISSION.
AND WE FEEL ARE HONESTLY THAT
THAT'S THE APPROPRIATE VENUE FOR
THIS DISCUSSION IF.
THERE NEEDS TO BE AN ANALYSIS OF
ANY NEW RESTRICTIONS ON TRAPPING
THAT'S WERE THAT DISCUSSION
SHOULD TAKE PLACE FIRST.
SO WE WOULD -- JACK YOUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
YOUR CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BILL GAMES
TO A REP.
KAMALA NOT FOUNDATION THE
CALIFORNIA DEAR ASSOCIATION THE
WILD SHEEP FOUNDATION.
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING FOR
CONFIRMATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
BERMAN UNDERSTATE ARCHERY
SOCIAIS XIN IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL [inaudible]
ANY OTHERS [inaudible] ONE NOT.
AS A HEAD FAKE.
OKAY VERY GOOD WILL BRING IT
BACK -- QUESTIONS.
I WISH TO OPERATE IS
SUBCOMMITTEE SO.
NEW QUORUM YET.
WELL I WANT.
TO THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I'M JUST.
THIS TERM RECREATIONAL TRAPPING --
NEW HELP SHED LIGHT ON WHAT.
MOTIVATES RECREATIONAL TRAPPING
INTERNAL OPPONENTS WOULD ONE
ADDRESS THAT AS WELL BUT THERE
BE A COMMERCIAL.
MOTIVE FOR WHAT'S CALLED
RECREATIONAL TRAPPING.
ABSOLUTELY AND I THINK IF --
FOLKS ARE INVITING PEOPLE ONTO
LAND FOR RECREATIONAL TRAPPING --
AND THEN THERE ARESUBSEQUENTLY
SELLING THAT FOR THAT THERE
PROBABLY STE.
ACTUALLY.
OPERATE OUTSIDE OF THE LAW NOW
ANYWAY THE IDEA I SUPPOSE I I
CAN'T SHED LIGHT ON WHY SOMEBODY
WOULD RECREATIONALLY.
TRAP AN ANIMAL -- OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S A VALUE PROPOSITION THAT
DOESN'T -- MAKE A LOT OF SENSE
TO ME -- BUT I'M A LITTLE
CONFUSED BY THAT THAT'S A LITTLE.
CHANGE OF OF COURSE THAT THE
OPPOSITION IS USING -- HOWEVER
IF SOMEBODY REALLY LIKES TO TRAP
ANIMALS AND YOU HAVE A PEST
PROBLEM ON YOUR PROPERTY -- I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYTHING AND
CURRENT LAW THAT WULD REQUIRE
YOU YOURSELF TO SET THE TRAP YOU
COULD HAVE A FRIEND COME OUT AND
SET THE TRAP.
TO DEFEND YOUR PROPERTY AND
WILDLIFE AGAINST -- JURORS ARE
INVASIVE SPECIES AND SO AS I I
THINK THERE WOULD BE AN AVENUE.
FOR SOMEBODY WHO GETS A THRILL
OUT OF TRAPPING SMALL ANIMALS.
AND I DO NOTICE THAT.
TRAPPING FOR DEPREDATION
PURPOSES TO A RADIC HE PASSED.
IS STILL PROTECTED.
UNDER YOUR BILL ABSOLUTELY WE
KNOW WE HAVE A NEW CHAIR PROBLEM
IN THE STATE AND THERE'S NOTHING
IN THIS BILL THAT STOPS PEOPLE
FROM TRAPPING -- NEW CHAIR OTHER
INVASIVE SPECIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
VERY GOOD.
CAN I AM.
I RECOGNIZE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
MAYBE FROM OUR WEST LINN
RESTORATION FOLKS BUT THERE MAY
BE NEW BUSINESSES NOW THAT
EMERGED.
AMONG OUR YOU KNOW WETLANDS
COMMUNITY TO SAY.
HOW CAN WE MAYBE?
YOU KNOW QUE IN THE
CONSIDERATION.
ALBUMS YOUR NUTRIA PROBLEMS AND
A I KNOW A LOT OF THE DISCUSSION
HAS BEEN AND APPROPRIATIONS
DISCUSSION WHICH ISN'T REALLY
THE PURVIEW OF THIS COMMITTEE
BUT FROM A POLICY PERSPECTIVE I
THINK IT'S HIGH TIME WE OF ALL.
STATE LAW HERE AND THERE IS ROOM.
PEOPLE ARE STILL GONNA
RECREATIONALLY HUNT IN THIS
STATE BUT THIS FORM OF PRACTICES --
BARBARIC IN MANY CASES AND IT'S
IT'S TIME FOR A CHANGE LOOK AT
THE DEFINITION OF USING A STEEL
JAWED LEG HOLD TRAP.
OR SOUGHT TO STORE SPIKE JAWS TO
DO SOME OF HIS WORK AND YEAH.
HAD YOU BROUGHT FORWARD -- THE
IMPACT ON THE FUNDS SEEMS
MINIMAL FROM THE ANALYSIS SO.
DID YOU GUYS HAVE ANY OTHER
FURTHER RESPONSES BEFORE MOVED
ON WE WERE HAPPY TO LEAVE THE
BILL ON HOLDEN AND VOTE WHEN WE
HAVE.
ALL COMMITTEE HERE BUT ANY
FURTHER RESPONSES FROM.
I'M WELL I JUST LIKE TO CLARIFY
BUT AT THAT AS FAR AS THE
RECREATIONAL AND COMMERCIAL
TRAPPING FOR LICENSING PURPOSES
THOSE ARE ESSENTIAL.
THANKS AND THERE WERE ONLY THERE
ARE A TOTAL OF SIXTY EIGHT
SUCCESSFUL.
COMMERCIAL SLASH RECREATIONAL
TRAPPERS IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN IT
IS A VERY LOW NUMBER OF PEOPLE
AND THE IDEA THAT THIS IS --
THAT THOSE FOLKS ARE
CONTRIBUTING IN ANY WAY
SIGNIFICANTLY TO PASS CONTROL ON
AGRICULTURAL LANDS IS.
A BIT -- A BIT HARD TO
UNDERSTAND AND AS THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN MENTIONED -- PRODUCERS ARE
ALLOWING COMMERCIAL FOR TRAPPERS
WHO DON'T HAVE A PEST CONTROL
LICENSE ONTO THEIR LAND
SPECIFICALLY TO TRAP ANIMALS
THAT ARE CAUSING DAMAGE TO CROPS.
THERE SUB THE AND THEN
SUBSEQUENTLY SELLING OUT FOR
THEY ARE.
SUBVERTING THE POLICY PURPOSES
OF EXISTING LAW AND POTENTIALLY
VIOLATING IT.
SO -- AND AS FAR AS I CAN SEE
HERE THE LICENSE SALES FOR
TRAPPERS GENERATED ABOUT.
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS SO.
IT SEEMS LIKE A GAP WE CAN MEET --
ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE IF YOU'RE OAK
SORRY AND COVER YOUR WILL.
ANDRES FOR GETTING HERE LIMIT
LATE BUT I I AM THANK YOU FOR
THE EXPLANATION IN TERMS OF AG --
ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT -- THE
ABILITY.
TO PROTECT FOOD SAFETY AND
ANIMAL PRETTY AND PREDATION ON
ON THE FARM OBVIOUSLY IS A IS A
CHALLENGE BUT I DIDN'T SEE
ANYTHING HERE IN REGARDS TO
NATIVE AMERICAN TRADITIONS AND
STUFF IS IT.
IT HAS THAT COME UP AS AN ISSUE
AT ALL.
ACTUALLY WHEN I FIRST INTRODUCED
A THAT WAS ONE OF THE THE
QUESTIONS I HAD AND NEED
AMERICANS DO NOT NEED A A
LICENSE TO TRAP FOR CULTURAL
PURPOSES.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WE FOR ANYONE TWENTY ONE MORE.
ALL RIGHT ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE AN
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON THANK YOU --
I THINK YOU KNOW AND AND I'VE
OBVIOUSLY I'VE THOUGHT A LOT
ABOUT IN AND ALTHOUGH I MAY HAVE
PERSONAL THING FEELINGS ABOUT
RECREATIONAL HUNTING THAT'S NOT
WHAT THIS IS -- I IT MAY HAVE
PERSONAL FEELINGS ABOUT
RECREATIONAL.
KILLING THEM AND BUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT THIS BILL IS IT'S SPECIFIC
TO TRAPPING AND WE KNOW THAT --
TRAPPING IS CRUEL AND AND CAN
HAVE -- UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
FOR ANIMALS THAT WEREN'T MEANT
TO BE TROUT ESPECIALLY WHEN
BEING DONE FOR FOR COMMERCIAL
RECREATIONAL PURPOSES -- WITH NO
BENEFIT REALLY YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
AS IF IF -- THESE LICENSES ARE
IN ORDER TO ADD TO STOP THE
NUTRIA WE'RE ALL FOR THAT THAT'S
NOT WHAT THIS IS ABOUT -- IT'S
OF A SITUATION I THINK WE HAVE
EVOLVED TO AND I HOPE THAT AS A
VALUE STATEMENT THAT WE CAN STOP
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BUT WHEN
YOU HAVE A COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SUMMER.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL LEAVE THAT -- WE
HAVE A QUORUM AND I'M DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER.
OKAY SO ASSEMBLY MURMURED SU CHI
WELL IN LINE HERE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE WE'RE STILL NOT AT FULL
COMMITTEE SO -- JUST A LIGHT A
PRESENT FOR THE MOMENT SO WE GET
A QUORUM THE WELCOME AND GOOD
MORNING.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
SHERMAN SENATORS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT TO ASSEMBLY
BILL.
THREE FORTY TWO WHICH WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA FIGHT.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S PLANS
TO FRACKING DRILL AND SOME OF
OUR MOST BEAUTIFUL FEDERAL
PROTECTED LANDS AND NATIONAL
MONUMENTS [inaudible]
THIS BILL.
IS A CONTINUATION OF THE GREAT
IDEA TO THE CENTER JACKSON.
A PROPOSED -- IN THE LAST --
SESSION THAT I SUPPORTED ON THE
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE.
BOB THIS TIME -- NOT TO FIGHT
THE OUR TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S
PLANS TO EXPAND OFFSHORE OIL
DRILLING.
BUT TO NOW -- TO ADDRESSES PLANS
TO FRACK AND DRILL IN OUR
FEDERAL PROTECTED LANDS THIS
BILL OR PROHIBIT HIBBETT.
ANY NEW INFRASTRUCTURE ON STATE
LANDS THAT WAS SUPPORT NEW OIL
AND GAS PRODUCTION ON FEATHER
PROTECTED LANDS.
AS MANY OF US KNOW -- THAT THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP ISSUED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT LED.
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR TO
REVIEW TWENTY SEVEN NATIONAL
MONUMENTS INCLUDING SEVEN
MONUMENTS LOCATED WITHIN
CALIFORNIA'S BORDERS.
A FEDERAL PROTECTED LANDS LIKE
BEARS YEARS -- IN UTAH HAVE
ALREADY BEEN OPEN UP TO OIL
DEVELOPMENT.
AND THIS YEAR OR LAST YEAR HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE BUREAU OF LAND MANAGEMENT
HAS AUTHORIZED THE DRILLING OF
NEW WELL AND IS THE INSTALLATION
OF NEW PIPELINE INSIDE THE WILD
FIRE OF FLOUR RICH CARISSA PLANE
NATIONAL MONUMENT.
NEAR SAN LUIS OBISPO.
AND OF COURSE EARLIER THIS MONTH
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OPEN UP
MORE THAN A MILLION ACRES OF
FEDERAL PROTECTED LANDS WITHIN
OUR STATE BORDERS TO POTENTIAL
FRACKING AND DRILLING. TO THIS
THREAT IS REAL BY PROHIBITING
THE ISSUANCE OF SUPPORTING
INFRASTRUCTURE LEASES AB THREE
FOUR TWO WILL HELP PROTECT SOME
OF OUR MOST BEAUTIFUL FEATHER
PROTECTED LANDS WITH THEN OUR
STATE'S BORDERS.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES HERE
IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
AND SUPPORT VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
SACRAMENTO COUNTY GREEN PARTY IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING AND FEDERAL MONEY
HAVE A SUIT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
A GOOD THANK YOU. ONE OF THEM IS
DONE WITHOUT AMONG CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
THERE'S AN RIVERA FROM OAKLAND
IF YOU TO CREDIT WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
BRENT AND ALSO SIERRA CLUB IN
SUPPORT.
THEN IT WILL -- CONNECTION --
THAN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU NEVER RIDE.
CONNECTION AFRICAN FULL SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IF ANY IN OPPOSITION.
THE NUMBER BRING IT BACK.
MEMBERS QUESTIONS SENATE JACKSON
CENTER YES I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL I THINK
THE APPROACH THAT WE HAVE BEEN
TAKING IS BEEN.
AN APPROPRIATE ONE I CANNOT
IMAGINE WHY WE WOULD WANT TO
START DRILLING IN OUR MOST
PRISTINE AREAS.
SO I WILL BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL AND I NOTE THAT I'M NOT
INCLUDED AS A CO AUTHOR SO IF
THERE IS AN AMENDMENT TO BE
TAKEN PLEASE ADD ME AS A CO
AUTHOR OF TO THEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- YEAH I I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS.
AS I WAS READING THIS IS I I
THOUGHT THAT WE HAD ALREADY
DEALT WITH THIS WHOLE ISSUE
BEFORE I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHY WE NEED ANOTHER VALVE.
I THOUGHT THAT THE THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF OF NOT ALLOWING US
ACCESS TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WAS WAS ESTABLISHED.
FOR THE OF THE THANK YOU SENATOR
THAT WAS THE BILL THAT CENTER
JACKSON.
HI AND I HAD WORKED ON LAST YEAR
TO DEAL WITH THE THE STATE
WATERS THE DEAL WITH THE ISSUE
OF OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING IN
FEDERAL WATERS BUT THIS BILL IS
SEEKING TO EXTEND THAT BASIC
CONCEPT. TO FIGHT OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S PLANS NOW IN
THE FEDERAL PROTECTIVE -- LANDS
ON LAND RATHER THAN OFF SHORE.
THE LASHES BILL WAS FOR OFF
SHORE.
THIS YEAR'S BILLS FOR LAND
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SOME MEMBER
FOR BRINGING THIS FOR I JUST
WANTED I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
FOR YOU ABOUT [inaudible]
SCOPE HERE.
I'M GLAD WE'RE GOING INLAND AND
NOT JUST STAYING OFF SHORE.
ENTER COUNTIES AT RISK AND
BARBARA COUNTIES AT RISK LA
COUNTY IS A RISK LOT OF THIS
RIGHT NOW OUR BACKYARDS OR
INCREDIBLY SENSE VERY SO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
NOT JUST ON THIS ISSUE BUT IN
GENERAL FUND ADDING THE HARD
FIGHTS HERE TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR NATURAL
LANDS -- TWO QUESTIONS THOUGH.
WHY NOT ALL FEDERAL LANDS THE
WIDEST FEDERALLY PROTECTED AND
THE OTHER IS ABOUT?
MAINTENANCE OF INFRASTRUCTURE IF
THEY COULD POTENTIALLY SLIP IN
TO SOMEBODY'S PROTECTED LANDS
UNDER THE UNDER THE AUSPICES OF
MAINTENANCE AND GET AROUND.
YOUR INTENT HERE SAID YOU MIND
COMMENTING ON THOSE ISSUES THEIR
LANE SO -- I I KNOW THAT -- THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
AMONG OTHERS HAVE EXPRESSED --
IN INTERESTED IN EXPANDING INTO
A NOT JUST FROM HER FEATHER
PROTECTED LANDS BUT TO ALL OF
FEDERAL LANDS.
ON IT -- TO WAS OUR ASSESSMENT
THAT.
TO THAT THE THE MOST -- URGENT --
THREAD HERE IS WITH OUR
PROTECTED LANDS OUR NATIONAL
MONUMENTS.
WE WANT TO START THEIR ARM.
WELL WE DO WE DO -- WE DID WE
DID NOTE THAT THERE WAS -- A
SIGNIFICANT -- EXISTING -- OIL
AND GAS DEVELOPMENT ON ON
FEDERAL LANDS ON AND SAID THAT
WOULD -- TO PROBABLY RAISES
SIGNIFICANTLY -- INCREASED LEVEL
OF OPPOSITION -- TO OUR EFFORT --
IF WE EXPANDED TO ALL FEDERAL
LANDS ALSO AT THIS POINT -- WE
WE ARE.
THAT WE ARE PRIORITIZE A TRYING
TO PROTECT OUR FEATHER PROTECTED
LANDS.
IN MY CONCERN IS THAT.
WE OVER PROMISE AND THEN. EIGHT
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION MOVES
INTO.
OUR BACKYARD.
AND CONTINUES TO DRILL IN THE
PUBLIC SAYS WELL I THOUGHT YOU.
PUT YOU KNOW I'M [inaudible]
IN.
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE AND THEN.
WE END UP IN A SITUATION WHERE.
THOUSANDS OF ACRES -- OPENED UP
THAT -- THEY ARE INCREDIBLY
VULNERABLE -- THERE MAY BE
OPPOSITION.
I I RECOGNIZE THIS THE BILL
BEFORE US TODAY BUT YEAH I I
WOULD CERTAINLY BE IN SUPPORT OF
AN EXPANSION HERE AND MAY BE FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AS YOU GO
FORWARD BUT LOOKING AT THIS
MAINTENANCE PROVISION. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT HAPPENS.
IS THAT THEY'LL PHRACK FIELDS.
YES TO MAINTAIN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO CLEAN OUT THE
PIPES.
REPAIR TO MAINTAIN SAFETY.
BUT IN SO DOING THERE'S A FAIR
AMOUNT OF EXTRACTION THAT OCCURS
AT THE SAME TIME [inaudible]
SO -- I DON'T KNOW HOW WE TAKE
IN THAT PIECE OF IT UP -- BUT I
GUESS I I WOULD JUST BE CURIOUS
WHAT WHAT LANDS THANK.
YOU GUYS HAVE A MAP OF WHAT THIS
WOULD ACTUALLY ENTAIL LIKE WHAT
WHAT WOULD BE ME MISSING HERE IN
TERMS OF FEDERAL LANDS IN THE
STATE BY NOT INCLUDING THOSE.
ISLAM IS IT IS IT PRETTY LIKELY
THAT A LOT OF VENTURA COUNTY IN
LA.
COUNTY IN SANTA BARBARA.
BUT THEY'RE NOT IN A NATIONAL
MONUMENT AREA THOSE WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE STILL.
I WOULD TO HAVE TO GET BACK TO
YOU ON THAT DAY ALL RIGHT.
YEAH THERE MIGHT.
THANK YOU MAY BE ALONG THE LINES
THAT THE CHAIRS ASKING I ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS. FOR THE ANNOUNCES SHE
MAKES REFERENCE TO CREE SO
PLANES NATIONAL MONUMENT WHICH
IS IN MY DISTRICT IN SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY.
IN A REFERENCE IS THERE THAT IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN YOUR OF LAND
MANAGEMENT APPROVED THE DRILLING
OF A NEW WELL IN THE
INSTALLATION OF A NEW PIPELINE
INSIDE THE BOUNDARIES OF THE
MONUMENT.
IF THIS WERE TO BECOME LAW WOULD
THERE BE WHAT WOULD BE THE
IMPACT OF THAT ON DISTILLING
IT'S APPARENTLY ALREADY BEEN
APPROVED WITHIN THE NATIONAL
MONUMENT.
YOU KNOW HOW IT WOULD.
AFFECT SENT [inaudible]
SO -- CLEARLY YOU KNOW THE THE
THE CHALLENGE THAT WERE FACING
IS THAT WE WE CAN'T JUST SHUT
DOWN -- WELL WHAT'S HAPPENING ON
FEDERAL LANDS AND SO WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE IT.
WE WERE TRYING TO DISINCENTIVE
EYES -- ANY ANY NEW OIL AND AND
GAS. TO THE EXTENT THAT.
THAT DOES IT IS THERE -- IS A
YOU KNOW ALREADY ACTIVITY TAKING
PLACE TO DEVELOP -- THE OIL AND
GAS DEVELOPMENT ON CARISSA
PLANES -- AGAIN WE ALL WE CAN DO
WITH THE INTENT OF THE BILL AS
IT IS TO TRY TO DENY THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WOULD BE
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT THAT.
MOVING ONWARD RIGHT -- MOVING
FORWARD AND AGAIN JUST TO BE
CLEAR -- FOCUS OF MY QUESTION
NOT NECESSARILY.
TO PROTECT THAT EXISTING OIL
DRILLING INFRASTRUCTURE BUT I I
WOULD THINK.
EXTENT THERE'S BEEN INVESTMENT --
PERMITTING.
IT WOULD RAISE AN ISSUE INCREASE
SO PLAIN.
IS ALSO THE SITE OF TWO MASSIVE.
THOUSAND ACRE PLUS SOLAR FIELDS
IT WENT THROUGH.
MASSIVE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
MITIGATION -- TO REACH THE POINT
WHERE THEY ARE NOW.
EATING INTO THE GRID THAT COMES
OUT OF THE OUTLOOK CANYON SO.
THERE'S BEEN A HUGE INVESTMENT --
SAFE RENEWABLE ENERGY PRODUCTION
IN THE CREASE SO PLAIN
[inaudible]
AND THAT'S THE DIRECTION I THINK
WE SHOULD BE GOING NOT.
EXPLOITING PREVIOUSLY UNTAPPED --
COMPLETELY AGREE CENTER.
BEGIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS
WHEN WE HAVE A CORPSMAN LED TO
BE SUPPORTIVE.
THANKS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBERS --
LET'S STAY IN TOUCH IS THE BILL
MOVED TO SORT OF PROVIDED GETS
ADDED COMMITTEE TODAY --
DEFINITELY SHE BRING FOR ALLIED
CLOSE.
IBM DIE I RESPECT -- MISS
SHERMAN YOUR DESIRE TO WANT TO
EXPAND THIS -- BEYOND JUST THAT
A PROJECT PLANS TO ALL FEDERAL
LANDS.
I AM CERTAINLY OPEN. TO HAVE IN
THAT CONVERSATION -- BUT FOR
TODAY.
AS FOR YOU I'VE.
ALL RIGHT WILL TREAT AS YOUR
CLOTHES AND WE WILL WILL BRING
THE BILL UP WE HAVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MEMBER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH.
IN THE SECOND ROW [inaudible]
NO LESS.
WELCOME AND GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND A SENATORS
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE THIS
IS MY FIRST SENATE COMMITTEE
MEETING SO.
I'M VERY EXCITED TO BE
PRESENTING EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY
SEVEN TODAY.
AB FOR SIXTY SEVEN WILL REQUIRE
EQUAL PRIZE PAY FOR BOTH MEN AND
WOMEN ATHLETES.
WHEN COMPETING ON STATE PROPERTY
IS FOR RECREATION?
THE SPORTS WORLD HAS
HISTORICALLY ENGAGED IN THE
PRACTICE OF PAYING WOMEN
MARKEDLY LESS THAN MEN.
ACROSS THE SPORTS SECTOR PAYS
DISPARITIES STILL EXIST FOR
EXAMPLE IN TWENTY TEN X. GAMES
THE FIRST PLACE PRIZE FOR THE
FEMALE CATEGORY WHICH IS A
SKATEBOARDING COMPETITION
DISSIDENT NOW.
THE FIRST PLACE PART PRICE FOR
THE FEMALE CATEGORY TO COME TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WELL HER MALE COUNTERPART TO
CALM FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THE US WOMEN'S SOCCER TEAM IS
ANOTHER GREAT EXAMPLE OF A MAN
AVERAGE 40% LESS THAN THEIR MALE
COUNTERPARTS ALTHOUGH THEY WERE
THE WORLD CHAMPION.
AND THE MELTING DIDN'T EVEN
QUALIFY -- NO PLACE ELSE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DO WE ACCEPT
PAY INEQUITIES.
IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT OUR STATE
LANDS REFLECT OUR VALUES OF
EQUALITY AND EQUITY.
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
ALONG WITH THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION DETERMINED THAT IT
WOULD ONLY LEAST PUBLIC BEACH
FOR THE MAVERICKS OF COMPETITION.
IF EQUAL PRIZE COMPENSATION WAS
GUARANTEED TO BOTH THE MALE AND
FEMALE CHAMPIONS.
AB FOR SIXTY SEVEN CODIFIES THIS
DECISION MADE BY THE COSTA
COMMISSION OF THE STATE LANDS
DECISION.
A COMMISSION TO GRANT.
ONLY IF THE PERSON PRICE FOR
BOTH MALE AND FEMALE CATEGORIES
ARTICLE. EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY SEVEN
ALSO CODIFIED IN PERPETUITY THE
GROUNDWORK LAID BY COUNTLESS
FEMALE ATHLETES THAT HAVE BEEN
ALSO STRONG AND POWERFUL
ADVOCATES FOR PAY EQUITY.
INCLUDING THE TO INSPIRING WOMEN
SITTING HERE WITH ME TODAY.
OUR STATE GOAL IS TO PROMOTE
EQUALITY AND EQUITY ACROSS ALL
SECTORS EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY SEVEN
ENSURES THAT REGARDLESS OF YOUR
WORKPLACE WOMEN ARE ENTITLED TO
EQUAL PAY.
AND WITH ME THEY F. CAM WOOZY
AND CASTING BETWEEN WILL
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES AMAZING
ATHLETES JOINING US HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS KIM.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
LEADER I AM THE CO FOUNDER OF
THE WOMEN'S SKATEBOARDING
ALLIANCE A GLOBAL CONSULTING AND
SPUR ORGANIZING AGENCY -- WE
HELP TO CREATE PRIZE PURSE
PARITY AFTER THAT X. GAMES THAT
TASHA REFERRED -- TO WE ALSO
REPRESENT A COMMUNITY
PROFESSIONAL AND AMATEUR FEMALE
SKATEBOARDERS AROUND THE WORLD
AND OVER THE PAST DECADE WE'VE
BEEN WORKING TO INCREASE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WOMEN TO
PURSUE SKATEBOARDING AS A
PROFESSIONAL CAREER.
I'M ALSO A CO FOUNDER OF SKI
LIKE A GIRL A FIVE OH ONE C..
THREE I DIRECT THE BAY AREA
CHAPTER AND WE PROVIDE FREE AND
ACCESSIBLE PROGRAMMING AT PUBLIC
SKATEPARKS IN IN SCHOOLS IN OUR
MISSION IS TO CREATE AN
INCLUSIVE AND EQUITABLE
ENVIRONMENT. FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN MARGINALIZED IN BOTH THE
STATE CULTURE AND SOCIETY WHICH
INCLUDES YOUTH WOMEN TRANS WHERE.
GENDER NON CONFORMING PEOPLE.
THEIR SKATEBOARDING WE TEACH
RESILIENCE CONFIDENCE LEADERSHIP
AND SOCIAL JUSTICE.
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
ADVISORY BOARD AT THE CENTER FOR
SPORTS AND SOCIAL JUSTICE AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY EAST
BAY.
AND THE CENTER IS COMMITTED TO
INCLUDE IT CREATING EQUITY AND
PROMOTING SOCIALLY JOSS
INCLUSIVE SPORTS THROUGH
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION.
SO WITH FEW BARRIERS AND VERY.
HIGH ACCESSIBILITY RATE
SKATEBOARDING IS A SOCIAL
MOVEMENT THAT'S EXPLODING AROUND
THE WORLD.
IT'S ONE OF THE FEW SPORTS WHERE
PARTICIPANTS GET TO LEARN AND
ENGAGE IN A PUBLIC SETTING.
INTERSECTING AGE CLASS RACE AND
GENDER DEPORTING TEACHES SELF
ADVOCACY RESILIENT SELF
EXPRESSION AND COMMUNITY
BUILDING.
SKATEPARKS HAVE BECOME A RADICAL
VEHICLE OR SKATEBOARDS HAVE
BECOME A RADICAL VEHICLE VEHICLE
FOR TRANSFORMATION FOR MANY
MARGINALIZED GROUPS INCLUDING
WOMEN AND SKATE PARKS ARE
MICROCOSM FOR SOCIETY.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
DISTINGUISH EQUITY VERSUS A
QUALITY HERE.
IS STARKLY SKATEBOARDING.
IN SKATEBOARDING WOMEN HAVE BEEN
EXCLUDED OBJECTIFIED AND TREATED
UNEQUALLY AND HAVING SPENT THE
PAST DECADE EFFECTIVELY
ELEVATING WOMEN -- EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE FOR THE SPACE FOR
WOMEN'S ONLY EVENTS BRANDS AND
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
WOMEN TO CONTINUE BEING HEARD
SPOT.
SPOTLIGHTED AND PRIORITIZED AND
THE CREATION OF EQUITY FOR WOMEN
STARTING FROM THE PAY LEVEL IS A
FOUNDATION OF ACHIEVING GENDER.
EQUALITY THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS KATHERINE
ROUTINE I AM A RETIRED
PROFESSIONAL CYCLIST AND FORMER
COLUMNIST FOR ESPN.
I NOW RUN THE HOME STRETCH
FOUNDATION IN TUCSON ARIZONA THE
NONPROFIT WHICH PROVIDES FEMALE
PROFESSIONAL CYCLISTS.
WITH.
HE'S A WITH FREE HOUSING WHAT WE
COMBAT THE GENDER PAY GAP.
THAT IS GOING ON BEHIND THE
SCENES AND DISMANTLING THE
ANTIQUATED RULES OF CYCLING'S
GOVERNING BODY.
WE WON A MAJOR VICTORY WHERE IN
TWENTY TWENTY FEMALE PRO
CYCLISTS WILL FINALLY RECEIVE A
MANDATORY BASE SALARY AT THE
WORLD TOUR LEVEL.
BUT WE STILL CONTINUE TO FALL
THROUGH THE LOOPHOLES OF
PROGRESS AND EQUALITY.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN WOMEN
PROFESSIONAL CYCLISTS STILL DO
NOT RECEIVE EQUAL ACCESS TO
RACES.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE MOST PRO
BICYCLE RACE SAYS AND THE UNITED
STATES.
AND THE TOUR OF CALIFORNIA IS
THE BIGGEST RACE.
IN AMERICA AND IT CONTINUES
UNFORTUNATELY TO HOLD WOMEN BACK
THIS RACE HAS BEEN AROUND FOR
FOURTEEN YEARS AND THE MANNER
GIVEN SEVEN DAYS TO RACE AND
WOMEN ARE ONLY GIVEN.
THREE AND THAT'S TOKENISM IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE AND IT SEEMS ALSO
VERY ON CALIFORNIA IN.
BUT THAT'S WHERE AB FOR SIXTY
SEVEN COMES IN.
HAVING EQUAL ACCESS TO THE ROADS
AND HIGHWAYS IN CALIFORNIA WOULD
SPECIFICALLY IMPACT CYCLING BY
ALLOWING MEN AND WOMEN TO HAVE
EQUAL REYES STAYS EQUAL PAY FOR
EQUAL PLAY.
IDENTICAL COMPENSATION ACROSS
EQUAL DAYS OF RACING IS
SOMETHING WE SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
FIGHT FOR IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN EQUAL ACCESS
NEEDS TO BE A GIVEN BY THIS
POINT.
AND CALIFORNIA CAN BE THE GAME
CHANGING STATE THAT STEPS UP AND
MAKES A QUALITY HAPPEN FOR WOMEN
IN PRO CYCLING AND MANY OTHER
SPORTS.
UNLIKE THE US BIG BOX SPORTS
THAT WERE USED TO THAT TAKE
PLACE ON FIELDS AND COURTS AND
RANKS.
CYCLING AND ALSO SURFING REVOLVE
AROUND ROADWAYS AND OCEANS AND
TO DENY WOMEN ACCESS IN ANY
SPORT IS WRONG BUT IT'S EVEN
WORSE I THINK TO SAY THAT WOMEN
DON'T DESERVE THE SAME ACCESS.
FOR USING LAND AND WATER.
I THINK THAT WE CAN CHANGE THIS
TODAY BY BY PASSING A BEFORE.
SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
YOU MISTER TIMBRES MICHAEL
YOSHIHARA BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
WOMEN LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
FIGHTING FOR EQUAL PAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
SHERRI PEMBERTON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT.
IN A SECOND THOUGHTS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
BEING ON DO WE HAVE ANY BETWEEN
ERRORS OR OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
BEING.
NINE WE'LL BRING IT BACK MEMBERS
ENTER MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I FIND IT
INTERESTING IN.
APPLIED THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION IN THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION.
BOTH.
FOCUSED ON THE MAVERICKS --
PERMITTING AS A WAY.
TO ADVANCE.
THIS OBJECTIVE OF A QUALITY.
IS THE FATHER OF TWO DAUGHTERS
AND NOW THE FATHER OF
GRANDFATHER OF TWO
GRANDDAUGHTERS.
TITLE NINE HAS BEEN A BIG
COMPONENT IN OUR LIVES BUT IT'S
NOT FULLY IMPLEMENT IN MY VIEW
INTEL THERE'S A QUALITY AND
ACCESS IN PRICES.
FROM.
IS A HISTORICAL FOOTNOTE I WAS A
MEMBER OF THE KOBE SKATEBOARD
TEAM IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AS AN EIGHTH GRADER.
BUT IT WAS ALL GUYS -- BUT ON
THE SIDEWALK WHEN WE MADE OUR
OWN SKATEBOARDS.
IT WAS GIRLS AND BOYS THAT CODE
EACH OTHER BEHIND OUR BICYCLES
IN HIT THOSE CRACKS IN THE
SIDEWALKS.
BUT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD AND IT PUTS A SPOTLIGHT
AND I THINK ON THE AMGEN TOUR.
IN THE NEXUS OF USING OUR STATE
HIGHWAYS AND PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT'S IT'S A GOOD PLACE TO FOCUS.
THIS ADVANCE SO.
THANK YOU AND WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM I'D BE HONORED.
TO MOVE THE BILL FORWARD I THINK
WE DO SO WHAT WOULD SICK ONE
QUICK MOMENT I'LL COME TO YOU
AND WILL ESTABLISH A QUORUM IF
YOU DON'T MIND.
OTHER OF INNER STRENGTH HERE
HERE A JONES.
HERE ALAN BURGESS CABALLERO.
WE ARE HERE HERTZBERG.
SPRING HERE HUESO JACKSON MONEY.
YOUR MONEY HERE RIGHT NOW THE
COURT ESTABLISH CENTER CABALLERO.
I WISH I COULD SAY.
I WAS A SKATEBOARDER BUT IT
NEVER WORKED FOR ME I I NEEDED
MORE LESSONS BUT I DO WANT TO
SAY -- THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR --
IN A PART OF THE CHALLENGE IS TO
BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
THIS RIGHT AND I THINK YOU'VE
NARROWLY TAILORED THE BILL --
AND AND I THINK IT'LL WORK
REALLY WELL I'M I'M I'M GONNA IS
PRETTY TODAY AND ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO SEE IF WE CAN GET IT LIKE A
GIRL TO COME TO THIS.
SAID THE CENTRAL VALLEY THERE'S
LOTS OF SKATEBOARD PARKS AND I
SEE NO GIRLS OUT THERE SO THE
MORE THAT WE CAN.
MAKE IT A SPORT WHERE A GIRL SEE
THEMSELVES AND THEY SEE THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO LEARN A
SKILL -- THE I THINK THE MORE
MORE IMPORTANT I MEAN THE MORE
WE CAN MAKE IT IMPORTANT TO THEM
AND AND GIVE THEM SOMETHING TO
LOOK FORWARD TO AS WELL SO THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
APPRECIATE BOTH OF YOU.
I I WOULD CAN KERR I I LOOK FOR
THE WHEN.
AB FOR SIXTY SEVEN IS SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR.
WE CAN GO ON A STATE WIDE TOUR.
BY BIKE.
A BOARD BY SURFBOARD VERY RARE
IN THIS COMMITTEE WE GET THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO PUT OUR SHOULDER
TO THE WHEEL IN THE FIGHT FOR
GENDER EQUITY SO I'M SO HONORED
THAT YOU HAVE THE CREATIVITY
LEGALLY AND AS A MATTER OF OF
POLICY HERE.
TO FIGURE OUT THIS IS
INTERESTING HOPE TO ACTUALLY
MAKE SOME PROGRESS HERE -- YOU
KNOW WOMAN TAKES OFF ON A TWENTY
FIVE FOOT WAVE SAME TWENTY FIVE
FOOT WAVE.
THE MAN AND THE CONSEQUENCES
JUST THE SAME AND GOING DOWN THE
HIGHWAY WITH CARS COMING SIXTY
MILES AN HOUR.
OR EVEN YOU KNOW I COULD EVEN DO
A KICKFLIP GROWING UP STEPHANIE
SO I'M I'M IN ALL OF THE WORK
YOU ALL DO AND I WOULD LOVE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR WHATEVER
YOU TAKE -- AS THIS IF THIS BILL
MOST FOR TODAY AND THERE'S NO
FURTHER COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE.
YES I AM THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND I DID NOT KNOW
THAT ABOUT YOU SENATOR MINING --
TODAY WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MOVE FORWARD PAY EQUITY AND
CALIFORNIA AND WHAT WE DO ON OUR
PUBLIC LANDS HAS TO REFLECT OUR
PUBLIC VALUES AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY SEVEN THANK
YOU.
UP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I'M SORRY I MOTION WAS FROM
SENATOR MINING THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THEN I JUST TURN.
HI.
HI JONES.
JONES I ALLEN OR JUST MIRO.
CAREER AYE HERTZBERG.
THIS PROVIDE HUESO JACKSON
MONNING [inaudible]
MONNING AYE.
THERE IS FIVE HOURS WE WILL
LEAVE AN ON CALL THOUGH FOR THE
AT THEIR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU
BOTH FOR COMING IN.
ALL RIGHT VERY WELL WE HAVE WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE MON YES.
YOU WANNA TAKE UP CONSENT OKAY.
YOU MIGHT JUST WIN TWO SECONDS.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR REAL QUICKLY.
EVERYONE'S AMENABLE -- A
PROPOSED CONSENT IS FILE ITEM
ONE TWO SEVEN ELEVEN TWELVE
FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN THAT'S AB
652-554-0711. 601-392-1430 TWO
AND A. J. R..
EIGHT I'M TING OBJECTIONS A WE
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AND THERE'S TIME I AM I JONES
JONES I ALLEN FORGES COME BIRO.
BIRO AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO JACKSON
MONNING.
MONEY NINE VERY GOOD WE'LL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS IN RECENT
YEARS TO OFFSHORE OIL OPERATORS --
FILED FOR BANKRUPTCY IN
ABANDONED THEIR DECOMMISSIONING
OBLIGATIONS LEAVING TAXPAYERS
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN COST TO PLUG
IN ABANDONED.
DOZENS OF WELLS AND REMOVE THE
PLATFORM.
AB FIVE FOUR EIGHT FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE CONTINUES LEGISLATIVE
EFFORTS TO REDUCE OR ELIMINATE
THE TAXPAYERS FUTURE FINANCIAL
LIABILITY FOR DECOMMISSIONING
OIL AND GAS INFRASTRUCTURE.
SPECIFICALLY ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE CODIFIES EXISTING
CRITERIA.
THAT CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION ALREADY USES REVIEW
APPLICATIONS TO TRANSFER A LEASE
FROM ONE ENTITY TO ANOTHER FOR
OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION.
THIS BILL ALSO CLARIFIES
CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL
REGULATIONS THAT A LEASE SEES A
CREATE A CRUISE THE COMMISSION
OBLIGATIONS WHEN THE LEASE IS
TRANSFERRED.
AND THAT WHEN THE LEASE ENDS THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTY CLAIMS
LIABILITY AND STARTS DE
COMMISSIONING WITHIN A
REASONABLE TIME FRAME.
FINALLY AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
CLARIFIES THAT WHEN A STATE
AGENCY UNDERTAKES A DE
COMMISSIONING OPERATION. TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
IT IS DOING SO UNDER THEIR
EXISTING POLICE POWERS I WORK
WITH OPPOSITION AND CAN REPORT
THAT THEY ARE NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR PARTICIPATING IN
STAKEHOLDERS MEETINGS I HAVE
WITH ME TODAY AS SHERRY
PEMBERTON WITH THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR WELCOME
MORNING THANK YOU.
SHERRY PEMBERTON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION WHERE THE SPONSOR OF
AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE AND IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
WE FEEL THAT IT WILL HELP
MINIMIZE AND HOPEFULLY ELIMINATE
FUTURE LIABILITY TO THE STATE
WHEN THE EXISTING OFFSHORE OIL
AND GAS OPERATIONS AND AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THE MEAT ON A WITH THE OTTOMAN
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
EXCEPT MY COUNTY GREEN PARTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
AND FOR THAT I WILL NOT BE HALF
AS SOON IN SUPPORT.
AND ALSO WE HAVE A SIERRA CLUB
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY IN OPPOSITION.
VERY WELL BRING IT BACK.
I'LL JUST START JUST QUICK
QUESTIONS A MEMBER NOW I'LL COME
OVER TO THEIR HERTZBERG SO --
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK YOU PUT
IN.
THANK YOU ALSO TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON IT.
SHE'S SHE'S WALKING ME THROUGH
WHAT YOU'RE ANTICIPATING NOW IN
TERMS OF THE TWEAK. TO CAN YOU
JUST WALK ME THROUGH IT IN REAL
TIME HERE FOR YEAH AND WE AND WE
ACTUALLY HAVE COPIES OF MEMBERS
WANT TO SEE A COPY OF THE
AMENDMENTS AND THAT WE HOPE WILL
BE TAKEN UP.
AT NINE IN THE WILL PASS THOSE
OUT IF. TO THE BRINK.
OF THE STRIP THANK YOU.
SO DO YOU WANT ME TO READ THE
WHOLE THING.
SHE MIGHT MY STAFF IS SAYING
IT'S JUST -- IS THERE ARE THEY
EXPENSIVE I THOUGHT THAT THIS IS --
YES SO IT'S UNDER AT ITEM BE.
ONE ON ONE SECOND THAT WOULD
WOULD YOU MIND JUST WE GET THAT
DISTRIBUTED WHATEVER SHE'S GOT
THERE THANK YOU.
ART INTERRUPT YOUR THESE ARE
MINOR IN TECHNICAL AMENDMENT
UNDERSTOOD.
WHAT IS BEING [inaudible]
PERSNICKETY.
YES BUT THAT MY STAFF IS THAT
THEY ARE TECHNICAL IN NATURE SO
JUST WANNA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD.
YES I'M SAYING IT'S IN BE -- ONE
ANY ANY OTHER PARTY AND CRIER IN
LIKE.
RIGHT.
SO PRIOR IS BEING STRAIGHT OUT
AND THEN.
UNDER ITEM BE ONE EIGHTY AND
UNDER BE ONE SEE ANY OTHER PARTY
THAT IS.
TAKEN OUT AND NOW SAYS OTHER
GOVERNMENT AGENCY [inaudible]
VERY GOOD -- MEMBERS QUESTIONS.
HERTZBERG LIKE YES LANCE
COMMISSION WHY IS THIS BILL
NECESSARY IN VIEW OF ELEVEN
FORTY SEVEN ONE ADDITIONAL
FACTORS.
JUST HAVE BECAUSE IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT A BOND ANY ANYBODY'S
INSURANCE COMPANIES GOING TO
LOOK AT THESE OF CONSIDERATIONS
IT SEEMS TO ME YOU'RE PUT IN
SUSPENDERS ON ON A WITH WITH
WITH THE BELT.
I JUST CURIOUS.
THANK YOU SENATOR THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION I THINK THAT THE SPELL
IS COMPLEMENTARY AND GOES HAND
IN HAD WITH SB AT ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN IT DOESN'T FOCUS SO MUCH
ON INCREASING THE BONDS WHEN
THERE'S A POTENTIAL LEASE
ASSIGNMENT OR TRANSFER.
BUT IT FOCUSES ON LOOKING AT
THAT THAT POTENTIAL NEW LASSIE
AND WHETHER THEY HAVE A GOOD
RECORD.
ARE FINANCIALLY ABLE TO FULFILL
THE TERMS IN THE LEASE AND THEN
IT HAS A NUMBER OF OTHER
PROVISIONS THAT ALSO PROVIDES
MORE TRANSPARENCY BY REQUIRING
THAT ANY ASSIGNMENT IS RECORDED
IN THE COUNTY WHERE THE LANDS
ARE.
AND IT IS MORE.
SPECIFIC ABOUT WHEN DE
COMMISSIONING A LIABILITY OR
COME ON THE INSURANCE COMPANY
REQUIRE THAT NOBODY'S GONNA
WRITE A BOND.
IT'S GONNA ACT THEY CAN ASK
EVERYONE THESE QUESTIONS IS
THERE CONCERN ABOUT THE REST.
THEY'RE GONNA MAKE SURE I GET IT
BUT THE METS WHITES BUT BUILT AS
SPENDERS THAT ARE YOU REALLY
SOLVING THE PROBLEM IF I'M AN
INSURANCE COMPANY I'M GONNA NO
ONE KNOW WHAT THOSE WAS.
I'M GONNA HAVE TO ENSURE AGAINST
THEM AND I'M GONNA WANNA
EVERYONE OF THESE FACTORS ARE I
JUST SIMPLY RESTATING WHAT
ADDRESS COMPANIES ALREADY DONE
NOTHING MINUTES NOT A WRONG
THING TO DO BUT I DON'T.
IS BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
SAYING IT BUT NOBODY WILL TAKE
ON A WRIST.
OR BOND WE HAD THIS PROBLEM
PLATFORM HOLLY WE DEALT WITH
THAT.
AND THE QUESTION IS I'M TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE NATIONAL
FACTORS THAT WOULD HAPPEN THAT
MAY BE BUT EVEN STATUTES VERSES
OPERATION Là BUT BY BUT BY
OPERATION OF OUR INSURANCE
COMPANIES WORK.
NOBODY IS GOING TO GO OUT AND
TAKE ON A RISK UNLESS THEY
MAKING SURE THAT THESE PROBLEMS
ARE TAKING CARE OF YEAH YEAH A
BIG PORTION OF THIS BILL APPLIES
TO THE POTENTIAL FOR A EXISTING
LESSEE TO FILE FOR BANKRUPTCY
AND LEAVE THE STATE RESPONSIBLE.
AND IN THAT CASE EVEN IF THERE
IS A BOND IT WOULD FALL SHORT OF
WHAT'S REQUIRED FOR THE FULL DE
COMMISSIONING.
SO THIS BILL TRIES TO SET OUT I
TOOK TO PROVIDE TOOLS AND
PROTECT THE COMMISSION IN THE
EVENT THAT.
THERE IS A BANKRUPTCY FIVE BEST
A FINE WHEN A LIABILITY.
STARTS IF THERE IS A LEASE
TRANSFER AND THEN ALSO PROVIDING
A COUPLE DIFFERENT OPTIONS IF
THERE'S A POTENTIAL TRANSFER AND
THE COMMISSION HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO CONSIDER WHETHER OR NOT
THAT'S IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE STATE.
THERE IS THE OPTION FOR THE
POTENTIAL LESSEE.
TO PUT UP FRONT A 100% OF THE
SECURITY FOR THE FULL COST OF
DECOMMISSIONING TO REMOVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ABANDON ALL
THE WELLS SO WE HAVE THAT MONEY
IN.
IN IN OUR HANDS RATHER THAN THE
POTENTIAL SCENARIO OF BANKRUPTCY.
IT IT IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN
JUST JUST THE BOND MECHANISM
WITH.
BUT AS A SUPER AT CHALLENGING
ISSUE IN THE CONTEXT OF OFFSHORE
OIL AND GAS LEASES BUT IT'S
REALLY BROADER AND PROVIDES THE
STATE WITH MORE TOOLS.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF ENUMERATION HERE
OF POWERS POSTED JUST RELYING ON
PRACTICE AND PROCEDURE -- THAT
CODIFICATION SEEMS SIGNIFICANT
ESPECIALLY BASED ON THE DALLAS
PROCEEDING I BELIEVE THERE'S
JUST A BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDING IN
TEXAS I'M NOT MISTAKEN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO
SOME OF THESE BILLS.
OR SUSPENDERS WHATEVER MAY BE
CENTER CABALLERO.
STILL BACK INTO THAT THE BELTS
AND SUSPENDERS THE MAY FIRST
QUESTION WAS WHY IS THE BILL
NEEDED IN THE SECOND ONE IS.
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE BECAUSE IF
YOU'VE ALREADY.
BEEN DOING THIS.
THEN THE QUESTION BECOMES WHAT
DO WE GAIN BY CODIFYING IT THAT
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE ALREADY AND IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT IF YOU SET UP A
PROCESS.
THAT YOU GOT THE AUTHORITY. TO
MAKE THAT PROCESS SIX FIVE AS
FLEXIBLE AS POSSIBLE AND ONCE WE
CODIFY IT THAT'S IT THERE'S NO
OTHER OPTIONS IN TERMS OF THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT THAT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT TOM.
TURNED TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM THAT YOU
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO SOLVE IT.
YEAH A COUPLE THINGS -- WE ARE
WE ARE.
ESSENTIALLY CODIFYING AND THE
FIRST PART OF THE BILL WHAT OUR
CURRENT PRACTICES WHEN WE
CONSIDER WHETHER TO APPROVE A
LEASE TRANSFER OR ASSIGNMENT --
BUT THE BILL IS IS.
IT JUST TRIES TO HIGHLIGHT WHAT
THOSE FACTORS WOULD BE AN BILL
IS IS ALSO IN RESPONSE TO WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IN IN RECENT YEARS
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN VENN ECHO A
MAJOR.
LET'S SEE OFF SHORE FILED FOR
BANKRUPTCY AND LEFT THE STATE
RESPONSIBLE.
FOR ALL OF THAT I REMEDIATION
AND FINANCIAL COST FOR THE
PLATFORM AND ALL THE WELLS AND
IT'S A REALLY IMMENSE COST AND
AN UNDERTAKING.
AND SO WHEN WE'VE REFLECTED BACK
ON ON THAT SCENARIO AND ALSO
RINCON ISLAND ANOTHER MAJOR.
OFF SHORE LET'S SEE WHO FILED
FOR BANKRUPTCY WE REALIZE THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS WHY WE
SHOULD GO BACK AND LOOK AT THE
STATUTE AND LOOK AT WAYS.
AND IT CAN BE UPDATED SO IN THE
FUTURE IF WE ARE IN A IN A
POSITION WHERE THERE'S A MAJOR
LESSEE WHO'S POTENTIALLY
TERMINATING OR QUICK CLAIMING
ARE FILING FOR BANKRUPTCY WE
HAVE MORE TOOLS.
WE REALLY WANT TO PREVENT THIS
FROM HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE SO
THE STATE'S NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE FINANCIAL LIABILITY.
OR FOR PROTECTING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY IN AN
ENVIRONMENT IF A MAJOR.
OR MINOR OFFICER OPERATOR FILES
FOR BANKRUPTCY.
SO I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING YOU
SAID THE WHAT ARE THE NEW TOOLS
AND THE NEW YEAH THE NEW -- AB
ABILITIES THAT.
ME AND AND LET ME JUST SAY THAT
I I SUPPORT EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT.
I GET WORRIED ABOUT GIVING
AUTHORITY AWAY IN IN CERTAIN
INSTANCES WITHOUT THEN TAKING A
LOOK AT WHAT.
WHAT ARE WE YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
IS THE AUTHORITY THAT WERE
GRANTING?
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO COME BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE OR THAT JUST PUT
IT ON AUTOMATIC PILOT SO I JUST
NEED TO MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND
THAT.
YEAH THANK YOU -- IT IS IN PART
CLARIFYING OUR EXISTING PRACTICE
SO AND IN THAT SENSE JUST
RELATED TO A CONSIDERING WHETHER
TO APPROVE A TRANSFER.
IT'S IT'S NOT PROVIDING ANY
ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY IT'S JUST
CODIFYING THOSE THOSE FACTORS
WHICH IS IMPORTANT IT'S ALSO
PROVIDING MORE TRANSPARENCY BY
REQUIRING THAT AT LEAST THAT'S
ASSIGNED OR TRANSFERRED AS
RECORDED IN THE COUNTY WHERE THE
LANDS ARE.
IT ALSO PROVIDES MORE
SPECIFICITY ABOUT WHEN THE
LIABILITY OBLIGATIONS A CREW FOR
DECOMMISSIONING.
SO IT'S VERY SPECIFIC WITH IF
THERE IS A LEASE ASSIGNMENTS BUT
THE COMMISSION APPROVES.
THIS BILL CLARIFIES IN LAW WHEN
THE LIABILITY -- STARTS AND AT
THE PRIOR OPERATOR IS NOT.
ABSOLVED FROM THEIR LIABILITY
OBLIGATIONS IT ALSO I CLARIFIES
THAT IF SOMETHING HAPPENS LIKE
WITH AN ECHO AND THE STATE HAS
TO STEP IN.
BECAUSE THERE'S A PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY AN ENVIRONMENTAL
HAZARD BECAUSE THE OPERATOR --
LET'S SEE ABANDONED THE
FACILITIES BUT THE STATE'S DOING
NOT IN THE CONTEXT OF THEIR
POLICE POWERS.
AND SO THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
PROVISION OF THE BILL THAT'S
ALSO IN RESPONSE TO WHAT WE
LEARNED AFTER -- THE FENNICA
BANKRUPTCY.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT.
TINO FURTHER CALL CHINS --
REMEMBER LATER CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU -- PLEASE CALL HELLO
ACTUALLY WE NEED A MOTION --
COVER YOUR MOVESTHE BILL THE
THE MOTION IS TO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS THE AMENDMENTS
DISCUSSED IT WILL BE ADOPTED IN
APPROPRIATIONS.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THERE'S STERN.
I JONES ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE FORGES. ZERO CAREER
AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO JACKSON
MONEY.
IT HAS FOUR OKAY THOSE FOUR
VOTES WILL BE THE MEASURE ON
CALL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY. THREE AMERICAN RADIO.
DO YOU HAVE A FILE NUMBER EIGHT
AB FIVE FIVE SIX GOOD MORNING
AND WELCOME [inaudible]
MONNING.
THIS THING ON OKAY.
THE MORNING WITH CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU.
I AM HERE TO PRESENT AB FIVE
FIVE SIX WHICH WILL HELP PROVIDE
OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES. TO
DISADVANTAGED YOUTH AND IMPROVE
THEIR OVERALL HEALTH AND WELL
BEING.
THIS IS SIMILAR TO THE BILL WE
RAN LAST YEAR AB TWENTY SIX
FOURTEEN WHICH ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND MADE IT
ALL THE WAY TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK -- AND SO HERE WE ARE AGAIN.
THAT MANY YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
URBAN AND RURAL COMMUNITIES AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE HAVE LITTLE TO NO
ACCESS TO OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES.
EVEN WHEN THEY LIVE MINUTES AWAY
FROM THE SPACES.
THE LACK OF ACCESS IS LARGELY
DUE TO EXCESSIVE TRANSPORTATION
AND ACCOMMODATION COSTS.
EXTENDED TIME OUTDOORS HAS BEEN
SHOWN TO DRAMATICALLY IMPROVE
INDIVIDUALS MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH PARTICULARLY FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE.
PROVIDING ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS
CAN ENCOURAGE GREATER CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT UNDERSTANDING OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY AT HAND.
AND CAN HELP FOSTER FUTURE
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP THIS
IS ACTUALLY SOMETHING THAT I
KNOW QUITE WELL.
AS A YOUNG PERSON.
THAT WENT THROUGH SIMILAR
PROGRAMS WHEN I WAS YOUNG AND
NOW HERE I AM ADVOCATING FOR THE
SAME PROGRAM STATEWIDE.
AB FIVE THIRTY SIX WILL TASK THE
NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCY WITH
CREATING COMMUNITY ACCESS
PROGRAM. TO ENABLE ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO REACHING
UTILIZED NATURAL EDUCATIONAL
RECREATIONAL RESOURCES.
THE BILL ALSO ALLOW FOR THE
CREATION OF A GRANT PROGRAM
PROVIDING SUPPORT FOR INNOVATIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS TO
FOSTER MORE ACCESS. FOR THOSE
WHO ARE OFTEN DENIED THESE
EXPERIENCES -- WITH ME HERE TO
TESTIFY IS JOSE GONZALEZ FOUNDER
OF LATINO OUTDOORS ONE OF THEM
IT ON ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF THE
POLICY FOR THE AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA.
AS WELL IF AND FOR THE WHAT IT
ON THE REPRESENTING THAT THE
NOVA DOORS FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THAT MAY ARISE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU -- BELIEVED
YOU ALL WITNESSES YES.
HI GOOD MORNING -- SO SAY WITH A
NEW BETHANY'S CONSIGNA FULL
SILENCE -- AND THAT'S IMPORTANT
FOR ME TO SAY BECAUSE I'M HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF LATINO
OUTDOORS.
AND ALSO THE SPONSOR.
OF THE BILL ON AB FIVE SIX FIVE
BY.
FIVE SIX IN.
I REALLY WANT TO STRESS A COUPLE
KEY POINTS ONE OF THEM IS THAT --
ME BEING HERE TO BE ABLE KIND OF
REPRESENT THE EXPERIENCE THAT I
HAD GROWING UP IN CALIFORNIA.
I GREW UP IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
ON EXCITED AND PROUD OF IT AND
I'M ALSO HAD THE OPPORTUNITY --
TO DO.
EDUCATION WORK IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA HERE IN
SACRAMENTO -- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE REALLY MY BACK MY MET MY
BACKGROUND IS IN EDUCATION IN MY
EXCITEMENT.
AND WORKERS AROUND THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN CONSERVATION --
EDUCATION AND OUTDOOR
EXPERIENCES.
IN A THE NOTICES THE UNIQUE
LATINO THAT ORGANIZATION WORKING
TO CREATE A STATEWIDE AND
NATIONAL COMMUNITY AND NETWORK
OF BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE THESE
EXPERIENCES. FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND ESPECIALLY WITH
THE FOCUS ON FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES WITH WHOM -- CAN
BENEFIT KNOWING THAT.
KIND OF THE PRESENT AND FUTURE
CONSERVATION STEWART'S AND
LEADERS OF OUR STATE ALL RIGHT
HERE AND I GET TO BE AN EXAMPLE
OF THAT AS WELL.
ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS IN NATURE
KIND OF SEEMS LIKE IT'S A
BIRTHRIGHT FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
I THINK AT TIMES HE WOULD TAKE
IT FOR GRANTED TO ME YOU SEE THE
PAINTING RIGHT BEHIND YOU.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE PROUD
OF AS A STATE AND TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S EQUITABLE ACCESS TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS THAT THINKING WE
HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO DO WELL.
I DO THIS RIGHT AND DO RIGHT BY
A LOT OF OUR COMMUNITIES -- WHO
DON'T HAVE THESE THESE
OPPORTUNITIES I WAS ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM INTRODUCTORY
OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES AS AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL STUDENTS ASIDE
JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT A
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT?
AND THEN EVEN AS A COLLEGE
STUDENT IN ONE OF THE KEY THINGS
WAS TRANSPORTATION AXIS ONE OF
THOSE TO KEEP THINGS AS BEING
ABLE TO GO.
NOT JUST ON SCHOOL SPONSORED BUT
ALSO COMMUNITY SPONSORED AND
JUST MY OWN FAMILY FINDING THEIR
WAY TO SOME OF THESE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND THAT'S WHAT'S PART
KIND OF THIS THE EXCITEMENT AND
LOVE FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS WORK.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS IS
BE ABLE TO SAY.
PHONE IS FOR THIS TO BE PART OF
A COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS
AND IT'S A CRITICAL REQUIREMENT
THAT ALL DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES ON UNDER THE PURVIEW OF
THE NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCY HAVE
THIS.
IS A DIRECTIVE SO FOR THESE
REASONS AND MORE WHICH WILL BE
ABLE TO SHARE AFTER THE SHOW
MORE ABOUT.
I WOULD REALLY THANKFUL FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COUNTRY YOU
OFFERED LEADERSHIP ON THIS
MATTER AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE VERY GOOD.
AGAIN WE'LL ASK YOU TO KEEP A
LITTLE SHORT WHILE THE MADE ON A
WITHOUT ON CALIFORNIA WE'RE HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
FIVE SIX AUDUBON IS COMMITTED TO
NOT ONLY.
MAKING SURE THAT WE PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND NATURAL
RESOURCES BUT ALSO MAKE SURE THE
CALIFORNIA'S ENJOY ACCESS TO THE
OUTDOORS IN.
THAT WE URGE AN AYE VOTE VERY
GOOD THANK YOU HOW MAY BE COMING
BACK TO YOU FOR AN EXPERT
WITNESS QUESTION MISTER ADDED ON
THE BUT OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERS RECALL MONSTER TO NOT A
WITH THE PUBLIC LAND WE WORK A
LOT -- IN PLACES THAT TOM
FEATURE COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T
GET TO GO OUTDOORS.
INCREDIBLY EMPTY.
STANDING OF WELL HOW THE WORLD
WORKS AND HOW THE OF THE
PROBLEMS WE HAVE TO FIX AN HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO OUR HEALTH SO.
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
RIVER NOW DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
AND ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP OF
THE CATHOLIC CHURCH AND ONE
STRONG SUPPORT OF VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SIR FOR ME.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
STEVE BAKER WITH THEIR NEED
ASSISTANCE FOR TENS FRIENDS IN
SUPPORT IT TAKES HER.
THE SILENCE ALICE WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY AND SUPPORT.
YOU.
NATALIE KNOCKS ON BEHALF OF SAVE
THE REDWOODS LEAGUE FRIENDS OF
THE LA RIVER AND MID PENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT. THREE SEPARATE VERGE ON
BEHALF HEAL THE BAY IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BRENNAN DAWSON SIERRA CLUB IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JAMES SO ON BEHALF
OF A SOUL AS WELL AS
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MATTEO CHROME HAVE THE MOUNTAINS
RECREATION CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MORNING MR CHAIR MEMBERS DUCK
HOUSTON REPRESENTING THE OUTDOOR
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
OUTDOOR RECREATION PARTNERSHIP
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK.
DISTRICT CALIFORNIA PARK
RECREATION SOCIETY SNOW COUNTY
PARKS IN SUPPORT VERY GOOD
THANKS.
FOR NOTHING IN HOUSE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
YOU.
OKAY.
SEEN OTHERS IN SUPPORTIVE ANY IN
OPPOSITION.
BEING NINE THERE'S A MOTION FROM
CENTER BOARD JUSTIN WILL BRING
EVER CENTER HERTZBERG FOUR EIGHT
QUESTION MEANT.
THE QUICK IS JUST YEAH I WON
BOTH.
I SENATOR YOU KNOW.
I REMEMBER WHEN YOU IN IN MALIBU --
LAST YEAR THE YEAR BEFORE MISTER
SHERMAN.
HOW YOU BROUGHT SO MANY KIDS WHO
HAD NEVER EVEN EXPERIENCE THE
BEACH YOU KNOW? TO THE BEACH.
WHEN I WAS CHAIRMAN OF THE
ROUNDS CHAIRMAN AS VICE SHAUN
TARA WAS?
OF THE QUALITY AND PRODUCTIVITY
COMMISSION. THIRTY SOME YEARS
AGO IN THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
WE DID SO MANY PROGRAMS ARE WE
WILL GO OUT AND MAKE DEALS TO BY.
VANS TO BRING THE KIDS TO THE
BEACH ROAD.
WHEN I WORKED AT THE -- THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE MON TOMORROW THE
MOST IN THE QUARTER SAME THING
IT JUST NEVER CEASES TO AMAZE ME
HOW.
HOW MANY KIDS WHO LIVE WITHIN
INCHES AWAY FROM HIS
EXTRAORDINARY NATURE CONSERVE IT
WAS TO JORDAN INSTANT DOES?
JUST WE CAN NEVER DO ENOUGH IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE THE STORIES SO I
JUST THANK YOU WOULD LOVE TO BE
A CO AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE.
I AND AND APPRECIATE TO THAT
YOU'RE DOING THIS AND KEEP UP
THE FIGHT IT'S JUST A NEVER
ENDING BATTLE AND WE'VE GOT IT
WOULD NEED TO PROVIDE THOSE
RESOURCES FOR ALL FOLKS AND BY
DOING IT FOR SO MANY YEARS IT
DOESN'T MATTER IF IT'S LONG AS
EVERYBODY GETS THE OPPORTUNITIES.
OF THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR CENTER CUBBY
YEAR AND THEN WE'LL COMMERCENTRE
BORDERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I
WON A SECOND WITH MY COLLEAGUES --
HAS TO SAY ABOUT.
THE CHALLENGES OF TRYING TO GET.
YOUNG PEOPLE FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES JUST [inaudible]
TO REALLY [inaudible]
CLOSE.
I'M PLACES ON THERE ARE MANY
PEOPLE MANY KIDS IN SALINAS AND
I'VE NEVER SEEN THE BEACH AND
IT'S PROP MILES FROM THE OCEAN
AS THE CROW FLIES.
I'M IN AND SO -- ONE OF THAT ONE
OF THE BUGS I WANT TO PUT IN
YOUR BECAUSE I'M I'M I THINK
THAT THERE'S A REAL NEED TO LOOK
AT THIS AS WELL AS THAT.
YOU KNOW BACK WHEN THERE WAS A
FISCAL CRISIS AND THE STATE WAS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WE
WERE GOING TO DO WITH OUR STATE
PARKS -- AN INVENTORY OF THE
PARKS WAS REALLY ILLUSTRATIVE
AND THEN WE GOT DATA ON HOW MANY
VISITS. TO THE PARKS AND THE
PARKS THAT WORD NOT.
AS BUSY IN OTHER WORDS COLLECT
MUCH MONEY WORD SLATED FOR
CLOSURE AND THAT ULTIMATELY WAS
STOPPED BECAUSE FRANKLY MOST OF
THOSE WERE IN WERE IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES WHERE -- THERE IT'S
NOT THAT NATURAL IT'S A
DIFFERENT NATURAL BEAUTY THAN
THAN THAT THE STATE PARK ON THE
BEACH WHICH GET A LOT OF
ATTENTION AND SO.
I'M I THINK THERE'S A REAL NEED
TO LOOK AT HOW WE FIND OUT HOW.
HOW ARE STATE PARKS ARE?
DISTRIBUTED THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND I A I A REPRESENT AN AREA
WHERE THERE VERY FEW STATE PARKS
AND WHERE IF THERE'S A STATE
PARK THE IVESTMENT IN THAT PARK
IS VERY.
LOW I'M BY THE STATE BECAUSE
WELL.
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS BUT I I
WANNA APPLIED YOU FOR THE IDEA
OF TRANSPORTATION BECAUSE IT'S
ONE THING TO HAVE A STATE PARK
OPEN.
BUT TRANSPORTATION OTHER PARKS
AS WELL IS REALLY IMPORTANT --
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT LIMITS
PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO GET TO SOME
OF THESE PARKS -- BUT BUT
THERE'S ALSO I THINK WE NEED TO
BUILD AND MAYBEIT'S THROUGH THE
NONPROFIT TO AS WELL THIS IS
THIS CAPACITY FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THERE ARE
PLACES THAT THEY CAN GO THAT
THEY FELT.
ARC THAT THEIR CULTURALLY
COMPETENT TYPES OF INFORMATION
ABOUT THE PARK AND THEY FEEL
COMFORTABLE GOING AS WELL SO AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE REALLY
IMPORTANT WHEN APPLIED YOUR WORK
ON THIS I'M IT IT SOME.
REALLY IMPORTANT I THINK WE'LL
GET IT TO THIS GOVERNOR AND I
THINK I'LL HAVE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO IT BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR AND
THANK YOU FOR TO THE NONPROFIT
FOR YOUR WORK AS WELL IT IT IS --
THAT.
MOST RECENT RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
IT'S NOT JUST THE PHYSICAL.
HEALTH IMPROVEMENT THAT IT'S THE
MENTAL HEALTH IMPROVEMENTS THAT --
THAT THE SPACES CREATE AND SO
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE PEOPLE
WALKING IN NATURE AND THE FEEL
THE SERENITY IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO SOME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER CENTER BORDERS.
WASN'T PLANNING ON SPEAKING BUT
CENTER HERTZBERG ANSWER
CABALLERO INSPIRED ME.
I TOO WANTED TO COMMEND YOU FOR
THIS [inaudible]
I WAS.
I WAS A I SERVED AS CHAIR OF THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
RIVER CONSERVANCY OFFER A NUMBER
OF YEARS.
AND THERE WAS A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY ONLY ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
METERS.
FROM RIVER ACCESS. FOR THE LIFE
OF ME I COULD NOT UNDERSTAND WHY.
IT WAS NOT MORE INTERACTION
BETWEEN THAT COMMUNITY AND
BEAUTIFUL NATURAL RESOURCES.
IN REPRESENTING THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WHICH INCLUDE SOME OF THE
MOST BEAUTIFUL MOUNTAIN RANGES
SO ON AND SO FORTH.
WHY INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT ENJOYING
IN USING?
THESE AMENITIES MORE OFTEN IS
STRIKING BUT YOU HAVE TO CREATE
THE OPPORTUNITIES THE PLATFORMS
WITH TRANSPORTATION FOR THE
AWARENESS -- SO I COMMEND YOU
FOR THIS DEFINITELY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT.
THANKS THEIR BORDERS I'M.
THANKS FOR BRINGING THIS BACK.
SECOND TIME'S GOING TO BE A
CHARM.
BUT I HAVE A QUESTION THAT'S%
SOMEWHAT TECHNICAL BUT ALSO --
RATHER TIMELY.
I WANT WE NEED TO PUT OUR MONEY
WHERE OUR MOUTH IS AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A POLICY
FRAMEWORK AND I I LARGER WOULD
LOVE TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL MOVES THROUGH WHEN I WANT
RESOURCE TO GET MOVING ON THIS
PROGRAM BUT WHEN FIGHTING ALL.
YEAR TRY TO GET COMMUNITY ACCESS
ELEVATED.
AND IT'S NOT LOOKING GOOD RIGHT
NOW LOOKS LIKE -- BUDGET HEARING
IN TINKERING AROUND NUANCES TO
BOND LAW -- HAS ONCE AGAIN
STALLED OUT OUR EFFORTS TO
ACTUALLY GET TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES YES LOW COST
ACCOMMODATIONS MATTER YES NEW
ACQUISITIONS MATTER BUT IF
KNOWING GET TO THESE
ACCOMMODATIONS OR ENTITIES NEW
LANDS.
THAT WERE WERE LAWSUIT DO YOU DO
YOU HAVE ANY FEEDBACK FOR US
MISTER ADDED ON THOUGH ON THE
STATE OF PLAY IN TERMS OF WHAT
WE'VE ACTUALLY GOT IN THE
PIPELINE TO MAKE.
THIS PROGRAM WORK OR WHAT MORE
WE NEED TO DO.
NOT REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT OF A
LITTLE KNOWN BEHALF OF LATINO
ADORES PROCEED QUESTIONS IN THE
COMMENTS FROM ALL THE THE
SENATORS.
SO -- AS AS IS MENTIONED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS -- THE
QUESTION OF FUNDING HAS BEEN THE
THORNY ISSUE ON ON THESE
PROPOSALS.
WE IN THE VETO MESSAGE THE
GOVERNOR POINTED TO PROP SIXTY
EIGHT AS THE REASON WHY THIS IS
ALREADY TAKEN CARE OF BUT IT
REALLY -- THAT THE VETO MESSAGE
FOCUSED ON TWO AND SEVEN SEVEN
MILLION FROM PROP SIXTY EIGHT
THAT IS REALLY DIFFERENT YOU
KNOW WHAT THOSE THOSE DOLLARS
ARE GOING TO BUILD PARKS AND
LOCAL COMMUNITIES USING THE AB
THIRTY ONE FRAMEWORK.
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AS AS
WE JUST HEARD IS BRINGING FOLKS
OUT TO THESE PLACES AND NOT JUST
A PARKS EITHER IN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT -- WETLANDS ANOTHER
PRESERVES ARE ALSO IN CENTRAL
VALLEY WHERE WHERE FOLKS CAN
ACCESS -- NATURE -- THROUGH
THOSE VENUES AS WELL -- AND MANY
OTHERS -- THROUGH DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS DFW AND WHILE THE
CONSERVATION BOARD SERRA --
SPECIFICALLY TO THE QUESTION OF
FUNDING FOR THIS YEAR WE ARE
AWARE THAT THE ASSEMBLY PUT
FORWARD A PROPOSAL TO TO MAKE
SOME FUNDING AVAILABLE IN THE
BUDGET -- IN COORDINATION WITH --
PROPOSALS ARE MOVING TO A
LEGISLATURE INCLUDING --
ASSUMING RECOVERY IS.
FIVE FIVE SIX SOME AND I THINK
THAT THEY'RE STILL POTENTIALLY
AN OPPORTUNITY THERE SO IF THERE
IS AN URGENCY IF THERE IS A
DESIRE ON THE SENATE SIDE.
I THINK WE COULD -- WE COULD
PROBABLY MAKE SOMETHING HAPPEN
THIS YEAR -- THROUGH THROUGH A
FLEXIBLE FUND SOURCES LIKE THE
UMBRELLA LICENSE PLATE
FUNDRAISER SPECIAL FUNDS SOURCES
ARE OUT THERE SO WOULD LOVE TO
TO COORDINATE A COME BACK TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION.
AT THE IF YOU'RE KIDDING THERE'S
TO PAIN CANYON BOULEVARD RUNS
RIGHT TO THE TWENTY SEVEN
SENATE-DISTRICT OUT TO BEAUTIFUL
BEACH TO PAYING STATE BEACH
PEOPLE SURF HAVE A GOOD TIME.
FORTY FIVE MINUTES OVER THE HILL
THERE'S CANOGA PARK.
AND MOST OF THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVE NEVER EVER SEEN THE OCEAN.
FORTY FIVE MINUTES YEAH IN A CAR.
GO TAKE A BY PUBLIC BUS AND
FIGURE OUT HOW LONG THAT TAKES
YOU.
THAT'S ABOUT TWO AND A HALF IF
YOU ACTUALLY MAKE THE CONNECTION
MAYBE THERE'S A COUNTY SHUTTLE
THE GETS YOU OVER. THREE TIMES A
DAY -- THE BARRIERS ARE NOT
ALWAYS OBVIOUS TO PEOPLE WHO
JUST GO ABOUT THEIR LIVES AND
HAVE ACCESS TO A CAR CAN MOVE
AROUND.
IT IS A LONG A WORLD APART AND
CULTURALLY IT DIVIDES US AND WE
GOT A BREAK THESE BARRIERS DOWN
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING US FOR
TODAY AND LET'S.
LET'S KEEP PUSHIN.
ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE.
Q. THERE'S A BEAUTIFUL PORTRAIT
OF YOSEMITE RIGHT BEHIND YOU I
DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO VISIT
YOSEMITE UNTIL MAYBE THREE YEARS
AGO.
AND I AM SOMEONE WITH RESOURCES
SO I CAN ONLY IMAGINE RULE IN
URBAN COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE NO
RESOURCES WHO CAN'T EVEN GET
ACROSS.
A MOUNTAIN TO GO TO A BEACH THAT.
INCREDIBLY CLOSE TO HOME THOUGH
THIS IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO ENSURE THAT THE
BEAUTY OF CALIFORNIA IS
APPRECIATED BY ALL FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN OUR
BEAUTIFUL STATE.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR STERN FIVE STERN
AYE JONES.
JONES I ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BURGESS BURGESS I'D
CABALLERO.
AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HI HUESO JACKSON MONEY.
SIX THE BILL IS SIX VOTES WILL
EVEN ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANKS SO MUCH.
WHO WHO DO?
WHOSE FILE ITEM NEXT.
BUT I THE DECEMBER FRIEDMAN HAS
BEEN PATIENT A SIR PETRIE-NORRIS
ARE YOU WILLING.
BUT WHAT WHAT WHAT HAVE YOU GUYS
WORKED OUT BETWEEN EACH OTHER
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT -- THERE ARE FRIEDMAN
EVEN WAITING.
BUT SHOULD BE QUICK.
AND SHE'S A FRESHMAN SO.
YES THAT'S A HAZE -- I'LL PAY
THE PRICE FOR THAT -- YEAH --
ALL RIGHT.
THIS SHOULD BE RELATIVELY QUICK
THANK YOU SEVEN EVER AND
APOLOGIES FOR THE INTELLIGENCE --
PLEASE PROCEED I WOULD LIKE TO
FIRST ABSOLUTE THANK MY ABSOLUTE
FAVORITE.
AND IT CHAIR AT HOME THAT
FAVORITE SENATE MEMBERS -- I
SAID AND MEMBERS I SAID AND
MEMBERS.
AB FOURTEEN FOURTEEN IS A VERY
SIMPLE BILL THAT HAD NO VOTE NO
NOVO TO KNOW OPPOSITION THIS
BILL SEEKS TO STREAMLINE WATER
REPORTING FOR WATER AGENCIES SO
THAT THEY BASICALLY HAVE JUST A
COUPLE OF DATES WHERE THEY CAN
FILE THE REPORT AS OPPOSED.
TO HAVING TO ALWAYS FIGURE OUT
WHAT MONTH A DIFFERENT REPORT IS
DUE WE'VE HEARD THAT AS WE
BETTER REGULATIONS TO AGENCIES
SOMETIMES COMPLIANCE IS
DIFFICULT THIS WOULD.
BE BASS FOR THIS SO THAT THEY
COULD KNOW THAT IN CERTAIN
MONTHS ALL OF THEIR REPORTS ARE
DUE JUST TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
THEM SO THIS IS STREAMLINING --
FOR WATER REPORTS -- I CAN READ
MORE DETAILS IF YOU LIKE OR WE
CAN ASK QUESTIONS I ALSO HAVE
WITH ME TODAY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL AND YOU HAND WITH THE LA
DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND POWER.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANKS SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IN
ASKING A WITH KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND POWER WE
APPRECIATE THE STAFF ANALYSIS ON
THIS BILL IT IS A SIMPLE CLEAN
UP.
IT ALSO MAINTAINS THE INTEGRITY
OF THE INFORMATION IN THE
REPORTS ASK YOUR AYE VOTE NOW
SEE THE TIME TO ENTER HONG WITH
A LADY W. P. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
WELCOME POINT.
MORNING THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
ANDREW HAN I'M A WATER RESOURCES
ENGINEER WITH THE DEPARTMENT
WATER POWER.
NEARLY DEPARTMENT WATER POWER IS
A SPONSOR OF AB.
FOURTEEN FOURTEEN AB FOURTEEN
FOURTEEN WILL AYE REPORTING TIME
LINES FOR EXISTING STATE WATER
USE AND RESEARCH REPORTS WHAT
TIME LINES REQUIRE THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN LONG TERM WATER
CONSERVATION LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE.
IS A CONSULTING FIVE SERVER
WATER YOU SUPPORTING DEADLINES
DOWN TO TWO WELL RETAIN THE
CONTENT RECORDABLE FIVE REPORTS.
AB FOURTEEN FOURTEEN WILL ALSO
ELIMINATE DUPLICATE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
LOCAL UTILITIES WILL BE ABLE TO
STREAMLINE THEIR REPORT
PREPARATION REVIEW AND
SUBMISSION PROCESS WILL BE ABLE.
TO EFFICIENTLY ALLOCATE LOCAL
RESOURCES TOWARDS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF WATER
CONSERVATION AND MANAGEMENT
PLANS.
THIS CAN CURRENTLY CONSOLIDATES
THE REPORT SAYS THE AGENCY STAFF
WHEN YOU TO REVIEW.
ADJUST THE REPORTING DEADLINES
ALSO RESULT IN HIGHER QUALITY
DATA MORE ACTIVE REPORTING.
THE CURRENT COMPLIANCE DEADLINES
RESULT IN THE MIDDLE OF
PRELIMINARY DATA TO STATE.
AND THE DEADLINE ADJUSTMENTS IN
THIS BILL ALLOW WATER AGENCIES
TO COMPLETE A PROVIDE COMPLETE
FULLY VETTED DATA SAYS TO THE
STATE FOR SUSAN POLICY -- AND
AND PLANNING VERY GOOD THANKS
SIR AS IN SUPPORT I AM JUST
BRIEFLY NIKITA CREDIT WITH THE
NOT TO RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
I PLEASED TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT
WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH THE
ORIGINAL BELT REALLY APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR EXACT ACCEPTANCE AND
CLARIFYING AMENDMENT
SPECIFICALLY TO ENSURE THAT.
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR URBAN
WATER LOSS REPORTING DON'T
REMAIN OUR NOT REDUCED UNDER
THIS BILL SO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS THAT WORK ON THIS BILL I
THINK -- WITH THAT THANK YOU
OTHERS IN SUPPORT REALLY A WHOLE
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES WE
JUST LIKE THINK THE AUTHOR HER
STAFF AND THE SPONSORS WORKING
WITH US TO ADDRESS MINOR
CONCERNS RENOWNED FULL SUPPORT.
THANKS MUCH.
JENNIFER WILLIAMS WITH THE EAST
BAY MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT AND WE APPRECIATE THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS THAT ADDED
FURTHER CLARIFICATION ON THE
REPORTING THAT LINE VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF HIS SUPPORT.
SEE NINE OTHERS IN UP ANY
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE.
MEMBERS QUESTIONS COMMENTS
MOTIONS -- MOTION FROM CENTER TO
JONES -- Là YOU TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU
ARE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR STERN HI STERN I'D
JONES.
JONES I ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BARGES BARGES AYE AYE
CABALLERO HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO JACKSON
MONEY IT HAS FIVE WILL GET US
FIVE VOTES LEAVE MEASURE ON
COFFEE AS MEMBERS THANK YOU.
OKAY SO YOU HAVE PETRIE-NORRIS
NOW THAT.
OKAY NOW MY APOLOGY TOUR BEGINS
THANK YOU AND APOLOGIES I
APPRECIATE THE INDULGENCE GOOD
MY WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
THINK YOU'VE GOT YOU'VE GOT ONE
MEASURE ON CAN SENSE.
AND THEN -- YOU CAN BRING TEN A
TEN ELEVEN YES OKAY VERY GOOD
HERE TO DATE YOU ASKED FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI TEN ELEVEN THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS.
TO ENCOURAGE THE PARTICIPATION
OF FIVE OH ONE C. THREES IN
HABITAT RESTORATION PROJECTS
ALONG THE CALIFORNIA COAST.
I HAD ANY DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITY
IN THE COASTAL ZONE REQUIRES A
COASTAL ABOUT DEVELOPMENT PERMIT
FROM THE COASTAL COMMISSION.
FEES FOR A CD P. CAN BE
CONSIDERABLE RUN INTO TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
EVEN FOR RESTORATION PROJECTS
ALTHOUGH THE COASTAL COMMISSIONS
REGULATIONS DO ALLOW FOR THE
REDUCTION OR WAIVER OF FILING
FEES THE COASTAL ACT ITSELF IS
SILENT ON HOW THE COMMISSION
SHOULD CONSIDER THESE REQUESTS.
AND ACCORDING TO THE COASTAL
COMMISSION LEE TO NON PROFITS
OVER THE LAST DECADE AND EVEN
APPLIED FOR A CD P. APPLICANT
FEE WAIVER.
AB TEN ELEVEN WILL PROVIDE
LEGISLATIVE GUIDANCE TO THE
COMMISSION IN ORDER TO ENCOURAGE
FEE WAIVERS WHERE APPROPRIATE
AND IT WILL REQUIRE THE
COMMISSION TO GIVE ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERATION. TO NON PROFITS
WHO WISH TO RESTORE SENSITIVE
HABITAT AREAS AND IMPROVE PUBLIC
ACCESS ALONG THE COAST.
OUR GOAL IS THAT BY PROVIDING A
CLEAR LEGISLATIVE INTENT HERE
WILL BE ABLE TO BOLSTER THE
PARTICIPATION OF FIVE OH ONE C.
THREE NON PROFITS IN DOING THIS
IMPORTANT WORK I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND HAPPY
TO HAVE.
TO OUR SUPPORTERS HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY THEIR CHRISTY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
AND FREDDO ARID ONDO FROM ISRAEL.
VERY GOOD WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING A CHERRY
COMMISSIONER SIR CHRISTOPHER THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION --
AS THE AUTHOR JUST STATED THIS
BILL WILL CODIFY EXISTING
COASTAL COMMISSION REGULATIONS
PROVIDING THAT THE COMMISSION
MAY WAY PERMIT FEES -- UPON A
VOTE OF THE COMMISSION AND
SPECIFYING THAT WOULD TAKING
SUCH AN ACTION THE COMMISSION
SHALL GIVE ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERATION TO NON PROFITS WHO
ARE SEEKING TO UNDERTAKE PUBLIC
ACCESS AND RESTORATION PROJECTS.
THE COMMISSION HAS VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY TO SUPPORT AB TEN
ELEVEN BECAUSE IT'S CONSISTENT
WITH CO SELECT POLICIES THAT
PROTECT THEM PRIORITIZE PUBLIC
ACCESS AND SENSITIVE HABITAT.
AND ALSO BECAUSE NON PROFITS TO
UNDERTAKE THIS WORK -- ARE
TYPICALLY DOING SO WITH LIMITED
FUNDS.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO NOTE THAT THIS BILL
DOESN'T IN ANY WAY LIMIT THE
OPPORTUNITIES.
FOR NON PROFITS OR FOR PROFIT
APPLICANTS -- UNDERTAKING OTHER
TYPES OF PROJECTS TO APPLY FOR A
PERMIT WAIVERS AND IT DOESN'T
LIMIT THE COMMISSION'S
DISCRETION WHEN CONSIDERING
THOSE REQUESTS AND APPLICATIONS.
THIS BILL SIMPLY PROVIDES
LEGISLATIVE GUIDANCE TO THE
COMMISSION REGARDING THE TYPES
OF PROJECTS -- DESERVING
ADDITIONAL CONSIDERATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN MR CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE ON FOR A LOT OF
ON THE ON BEHALF OF US SOON.
I'LL BE BRIEF I THINK EVERYBODY --
AND THE AND THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
FOR CARRYING THIS PIECE
LEGISLATION AND AND VERY
ARTICULATELY STATING THE THE
REASONS THAT WE ALL UNDERSTAND --
WE ALL KNOW THAT COSTA
RESILIENCE AN ANNOTATION ALONG
OUR COAST LINES -- IS A PRESSING
ISSUE AND THE MORE THAT WE CAN
DO TO LOW TO REMOVE OBSTACLES
AND BARRIERS FOR THE KIND OF
WORK THAT WE ONLY NEEDS TO
HAPPEN.
BOTH IN RESTORATION OF IMPORTANT
AND SENSITIVE HABITATS -- BUT
ALSO IN ENSURING ACCESS TO THOSE
COASTLINES -- IS GOING TO BE
CRITICAL TO ENGENDERING THE
PUBLIC SUPPORT NON PROFITS THEY
WORK WITH COMMUNITIES BAIT USE
VOLUNTEERS TO DO THESE PROJECTS
AND BEING ABLE TO INVOLVE A
LOCAL COMMUNITY AND THESE KINDS
OF OF PROJECTS IS ESSENTIAL TO
ENSURING THAT THAT COMMUNITY
THAN CARES.
THAT MUCH MORE DEEPLY ABOUT
THEIR AND THEIR COMMUNITY IN THE
COASTLINE FOR THESE REASONS A
SERVICES FROM SUPPORT VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SO MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
TONY BLAIR WITH THE A CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION HERE
SUPPORT.
GOOD THANK YOU.
RECALL MUSTARD AN AUTO WITH THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND REALLY ONE
ONLINE MY THOUGHTS WITH ALFREDO
SENTENCE.
JAMIE GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF FUN
AND SUPPORT.
AND ALSO THE SIERRA CLUB -- IN
SUPPORT.
NATALIE KNOCKED ON BEHALF OF MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT SEEING NINE
ANY IN OPPOSITION SEEING NONE
MEMBERS QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS OUT -- THE BILL -- I
LOVE YOUR COAST A PARTIAL MY
STRETCH GOES BUT IT'S ONE COAST
AND IT'S ONE CALIFORNIA SO IT'S
TIME WE OPENED UP FOR
OPPORTUNITIES AND APPRECIATE THE
WORK YOU ARE DOING.
DID YOU WANT TO CLOSE DID YOU.
I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
I'VE HAD VERY GOOD HERE THANK
YOU SO MUCH -- WE WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION AT THIS POINT.
SO MOVE FROM SENATOR BOARD JUST.
THAT MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR STERN AYE STERN AYE
JONES I'VE JONES I ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BURGESS.
OR JUST AYE CABALLERO.
AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO JACKSON
MONNING THAT IS FILE PRINT OKAY
THAT IS FIVE LEAVE THE MEASURE
ON CALL THANK YOU.
INTELLIGENCE.
DURING MY HAZING.
WE ARE.
AND I THINK WE ARE GOING.
TO NOW LIVE SOME CALLS HERE FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS TO HAVE ANY OTHER.
AND I THINK THAT'S IT RIGHT.
OKAY BUT OTHER THAN THAT WE MAY
NEED TO OREGON FOR MONEY WE CAN
START TO FEEL LIKE -- OKAY GO
WE'VE GOT JACKSON.
WHAT DO SPECIAL ONE FOR MINING
SO YOU GUYS CAN ALL GET MOVING
WITH YOUR DAY -- IF YOU ALL ARE
READY WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GONNA
LIVE CALLS AND AND ROLL THROUGH --
DO WE NEED TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SO WE'LL START OVER THE CONSENT
CALENDAR -- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE S. MEMBERS SENATORS ALAN.
I'M SORRY FOR THIS FO CONSENT
CALENDAR [inaudible]
WITH YOUR ALLEN AYE FORGES.
THIS IS CAN SET YOUR OWN FILE
SORRY FILE ITEMS.
ONE TWO OKAY SO IT'S FILE AND
ONE TO SEVEN ELEVEN TWELVE
FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN OKAY
BECAUSE OF MERGERS. FOR JUST AYE
VERY GOOD -- PLACE OF JACKSON.
JACKSON HI OKAY WE WILL LEAVE
THAT MEASURE UNCLE'S SO WE'RE
GOOD -- WE'LL CLOSE THAT OUT.
OKAY SO CONSENT IS DONE THEN
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO FILE ITEM
THREE EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY THREE
GONZALEZ MOTIONS TO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS.
AND WE ARE LOOKING FOR A MOTION
ON THAT MEASURE.
THERE'S A MOTION -- DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CENTER STERN AYE STERN AYE
JONES.
JONES NO ALAN.
ELLEN I BURGESS.
OR JUST NOW CABALLERO CAREER AYE
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO JACKSON.
JACKSON I MONEY MAKING THE CALL
FOR NOW I WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS -- LET'S
MOVE ON FILE IN FIVE EIGHTY
THREE FORTY TO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS.
I'M SORRY WE NEED A MOTION ON
THAT.
ONE TWO EIGHT MOTION FOR THEIR
JACKSON -- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
YOU PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR STERN AYE STERN AYE
JONES.
JONES I AM VERY.
THIS IS THREE FORTY TWO YES OR
NO JONES TO KNOW [inaudible]
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BURGESS.
OR JUST NO CABALLERO.
CAREER I HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG BY HUESO JACKSON.
JACKSON I MONEY.
THAT HAS THIS WILL PUT IT ON THE
GIVER GET FIVE VOTES WILL BE THE
MEASURE OF CALL MOVING ON A FILE
ITEM.
SIX BILL CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE
ZERO VOTE -- PLEASE CALL THE AS
AN AND CENTERS ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BARGES. EIGHTY FOUR
SIX SEVEN OKAY.
HI SO.
JACKSON [inaudible]
JACKSON MY SOME I MONEY. SEVEN
ZERO SEVEN ZERO WE WILL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS -- SORRY FELON NINE
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY FIVE A MOAN
MOTIONS TO PASTOR APPROPRIATION
CURRENT WAS FOUR ZERO PLEASE
CALL THE UPS MEMBERS SENATORS
JONES.
JONES NO FORGES.
FORGES NO HUESO JACKSON.
JACKSON HI THAT HAS FIVE IS FIVE
TO TWO WAS ON CALL FOR THE TWO
OF THE THE MEASURE ON COFFEE AS
A MEMBER.
OF ANY MEMBER.
TEN A. B. -- TEN ELEVEN KERN WAS
SIX ZERO MOTIONS TO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTER HUESO JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MONNING IS SEVEN
ZERO ZERO WILLIE THE MEASURE ON
CALL AND FINALLY OF FILING OR
THIRTEEN A. B.. FOURTEEN
FOURTEEN FRIEDMAN MOTIONS TO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTERS FIVE ZERO YOUR
WEDDING I SENATOR CABALLERO
CABALLERO I'D HUESO JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MONEY TO SEVEN ZERO
THREE GOOD.
ALL RIGHT THE WORK TO MAKE
MEMBERS YEAH [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
YEAH
.
ROOM WITH THE CALL ON FEW FILE
ITEMS HERE SO PHONE NUMBER THREE
AB TWO SEVENTY THREE MOTIONS TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR
MONNING.
MONNING EYES OUT SET MEASURES AT
SIX TWO FILE IN FIVE AB THREE
FORTY TWO MURATSUCHI MOTIONS TO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR
MONEY.
MONNING I'D HAVE CELLS THAT
MEASURES AT SIX TWO FILE ITEM
EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE FIVE SIX
CARILLO MOTIONS TO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS CENTER MONEY.
MONEY HI THAT MEASURES OUT.
EIGHT ZERO FIVE NINE NINE EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE LIMO MOTIONS TO
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
UNDERMINING.
MONEY NINE SIX TWO VERY GOOD SIX
TO THE MEASURES OUT FILE AND TEN
A. B. TEN ELEVEN PETRIE-NORRIS
MOTIONS TO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
CENTER MONEY.
MONEY HI THIS IS OUT EIGHT ZERO
FINALLY -- FOR THEM THIRTEEN AB
FOURTEEN FOURTEEN MOTIONS TO
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS CENTER
MONEY.
MONEY I GET A MEASURES AT EIGHT
ZERO IN THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED